I was
[Music]
you
Oh
[Music]
in my books you never turn Abuja down I
can think of a couple reasons to what uh
welcome aboard everybody what episode is
this oh I don't know maybe it's Episode
one [ __ ] hundred oh we made it
with [ __ ] okay like we made it look how
far we've come now baby HML whoo that
voices making is long-awaited return
very happy to have them here there's one
guest we're going to have for episode
100 it is and there's a head we can only
have one guest that really at one extra
mic that's why you're they need to have
we need have to wit you damage a little
bush bad you need to get re well we only
have one mic so we had to choose between
all those people you know who we pick of
the Andrew do it podcast check out his
patreon plea and also sort of the power
pals podcast yeah formerly of what was
the video game comedian the gimmick
podcast and a little podcast called
erection town USA
ladies and gentlemen dome you low
intrude away lllll a well hey everybody
it's me entered a wedding boy is it good
to be here
I'm stuff going on in the news today
coming out with a monologue I like it I
like it yeah you have any thoughts on
Russia maybe we should do like a Byron
Allen comics unleashed
so Andrew you've been ride your bike a
lot lately huh how's that going I've
been riding my bike around Russia and a
boy does it look like they hacked the
elections you guys read about this about
the election in Russia we hack elections
in the u.s. election hacks you yeah come
here not got a lot of new material Sean
politically do political stuff now I'm
sure he is I don't know if is that true
isn't he like a supervisor
shouldn't he be amusing performing in
Branson Missouri so he literally dude
he's in Branson Missouri he seems like
he should be good friends with Bronson
Pinchot yeah dude no Bryan pin shots
like a legit Talent I'm not saying
talent wise I'm you know because of the
Balki character they're associated in my
mind I'm don't you ever put yak milk
smeared up in the same category bronson
pinchot real name Yakov Smirnoff yes it
is it's his Christ given name he's
probably Jewish your name I would assume
Jewish you would think so but he want a
sense he's not Jewish no you know a lot
about Jack are smeared I'm going did you
run yeah yeah when you run a sweater
account sometimes the world looks
perfect are you talking to rearrange
you're talking about you're talking
about Malkina get the feeling that you
need some kind of change no matter what
the odds are this time nothing's gonna
stand in my way
with a flame in my heart and a long-lost
friend gives every doctrine and this is
perfect patience a man like the musical
bird cage is a musical with the wind and
thunder the rain haze seemed bound
better days it's my life my dream
nothing's gonna stop me now listen
that's a long theme song they don't have
theme songs that long anymore
yeah he's really not gonna cut them down
yeah your big go to a theme song karaoke
I like that one I like to David the
gnome Thank You Chuck oh you are big
David the no guy like everywhere you go
everywhere ha ha ha
where this whole house I think I like
this norc's I was just thinking it
earlier today
it goes swim along with the smart know
maybe it's oh here and there everywhere
or whatever it's just our party oh I
thought always a snork
Smurfs is here in their gummy bears
gummy bears that's it don't we bet
that's the one I know me bears it's
parked here there and everywhere
bouncing dashing and daring courageous
and caring faithful and friendly with
stories to tell all through the forest
they sing and chorus marching along as
[Music]
there is air and everywhere high
adventure this beyond compare bring all
the gummy bear house it was only like
five of them I know I don't get it like
bears they never explain like how
anyone's born
now who was Papa Smurf [ __ ] it wasn't
summer fact she was all the other
people's agent now now they now came out
of the ground or he was a single parent
grandparent - like a large village I
think it's why who died
mama Smurf yeah grand all boys and one
girl yeah you know at some point she
died in childbirth with hefty Smurf at
was definitely molested at some point
because you know the goofy one
remember when ratings were down and they
brought in the new kids who were their
parent they were like young submersed
kids yeah they were young remember
there's like a new generation where they
come first a new batch no they were like
on the jury or among their honorable
dead on the show secret disease
maybe Gargamel was really the real
question is gummy bears had nothing to
do with gummy bears
well they bad can [ __ ] yes just like
regular gummy bears before you eat them
don't some of your [ __ ] in your mouth
what are you talking about it I mean a
gummy bear often chick says Oh what you
this is new territory for you and I
believe I put an inner ass and Hammer
[ __ ] the gummy bear in a moment you put
so I'll tell you who would hate and hear
that Earl Skakel curl if you're
listening keep listening
listening I'm sorry no he's not at all
and I would do it I would eat a beer
oh we can look at offs of tip of the
duty or would you bite late now duty in
it so you're saying sugar oh you're you
want to do like ass tulips push it out
as you pushing no she I push it in G
forces back push it in sorry but it
tastes good in your mouth the teacher
teach the teachers gonna poo yeah it's
the rebooted gummy bears square feet
gummy bears just come out of a chick
bass push it back in with your tongue so
she pulls it back out you put him back
in good news is we keep a woman in here
with a gummy bear held in her ass in
case anyone ever brings himself no one
ever has I know I think usually call is
that acid gummy bear dispensary it's
funny but lastly it so has this
beautiful chick walked in here with a
big booty cakes and gummy bear depuis
tj's that is that your bakery by your
passing I've been testing out but jinx
is calling them booty cakes cakes I like
it they frosted and it will be what it
is hey I think we're off to an asteroid
episode 100 start and why not keep it
remote going it is from whose is from
this is from white bread Willy white
bread by the way Barbara is retiring my
longtime assistant where there's a
letter barb wants me to read I'm going
to do it next episode the retirement
letter he's resigning ultimate ethers
give us a two-week notice at least I
think she's done after episode 100 after
this we're on our own
we ever say it I got an assistant now
what's her name her name is Sharon but
she could she could you work double time
machine works double time shooting those
gummy bears my mouth okay
that's a lot of her jabbers yeah she has
nothing to do with the podcast it's just
literally I want a gummy bear spread
your butt cheeks cause I'm a businessman
does she work as a movie section since
you seem so you take it out of the
wrapper you put it in there you spread
the cheeks
Deadpool that comes out seems like it
this when you like to see what happens
there's gummy bears what when they go in
the ass silly I cover the duty and then
they come out go to your mouth I don't
get Doody Joe's like right around the
hole I need to go in a little deep into
I'm pretty deep yeah there's going to be
a little bit you have to go is lingering
around the guy so deep put the butt to
sleep yeah
I skew I didn't really do if you're
going to be an [ __ ] company dispenser
er you really you really have to watch
what you eat need a clean hole yeah in
my mouth from you Scylla in my mouth
coming from way down on sound you want
you want to smell like sex and candy
I smell ass and candy well it's injured
share your doing their usual Monday
morning routine that was a tribute to
the late Chris Cornell was is this room
Vice apparently as surgeries Reno
rejuvenation anal really on the rise and
I think if anyone can wait I think edges
might be opposed to so we'll see I think
I might be you wanted all natural and
starts off in 2010 with a man by the
name of Tom G with the star they reveal
that Tom G's not his real last name no
relation to Kenny G the lowercase C it's
a capital okay he went to see a surgeon
about getting skin tags are moving
around his butthole she had some tags
Jesus Christ yeah
who gives a [ __ ] you gay oh okay it's a
sexually active gay man this wasn't just
a routine clean up for like a fresh coat
of paint that's what he's a vice getting
some humor in here yes the surgeon he
saw not only removed the tags but he
also took out some internal hemorrhoids
and anal dysplasia aka precancerous
cells along with them thought he was
doing him a favor yeah turns out Tom
said the surgeon was too aggressive and
he didn't consider that his blood hole
was also a sexual organ hope Tommy the
48 year old man said it was horrific it
was on the sofa for three months in
horrible pain it was six years ago and I
still can't have anal sex comfortably
which has destroyed 50% of my sexuality
I can't explain the emotional toll
Otacon me Tom thought about like just
super Lubin it up I don't know about a
year ago though Tom found the fine anal
doctor dr. Evan Goldstein frequently
he's the founder of bespoke surgeon on a
leading practitioner in the burgeoning
field of anal rejuvenation he's getting
in on the front line Jesus anal
rejuvenation movement you imagine being
like so do you want to specialize in
well definitely going into anal
rejuvenation here's where it seems like
that might be a hot field to get into
know the family plow is going to make
mr. mrs. Goldstein happy because they
sent me to medical school when I see a
patient look me in the eye and say I can
finally get 50 dicks in my ass would you
know it was all worth it and would I get
those letters and they say I get my a/c
it seems like the [ __ ] of a 14 year
old it just makes it all work if you
send a video look how good I'm getting
plowed here doc yeah what if people just
want them for cleaner breaks this is the
highest anal sex rated video on xhamster
and I owe it to you doc this is Navin
all the videos for the farm forget you
should and it's a joy your ass will look
like this one right here so to advertise
good advertise
what are you porn for your home is where
Tom G this is this is where I found that
I like Tom being the type of
conversations he had with dr. ghost is
that I told them look if I can't get
[ __ ] at least make my butthole look
pretty
this guy's got you boiled life down to
its simplest parts so we need to put
glitter on it here's a sticker it is
plus some hair there's beautiful
inscriptions I'm going to put on the
side he popped it and grown hair Oh God
he put barrettes on his [ __ ] hair he
braids if it said I'll get some cornrows
other side it said and then the next
line from vison and he did he made it
look prettier picture of it a before and
after or particularly oh come on it says
says gay men obviously anals a big deal
for them
yeah but over the past few decades it's
gone from hetero taboo to nearly passe
whoo yeah Superbus attack what do you
[ __ ] her in the ass loser
yeah the pussy's awful look it's
nowadays and as the normalization of as
play grows Andrew would you agree with
that is this everyone else you still
think it should be a fringe thing or do
you like that it's become yeah you like
it does a band you like before everyone
thought they were cool and now you're
like boring I don't know how I feel
about it you don't know how you feel
about it anymore
yeah wow you're different too it's a
minute ago you were in the gummy play
ass oh no no I mean I don't know how to
feel about other people joining the
pouty where now it's just become a oh
yeah of course I've been eating gummy
bears out of my wife's [ __ ] yeah
that's where we keep our dishes all the
candy is your mom's ass okay you're not
getting any until you brush your teeth
ah because of that arising classic
doctors dermatologists foking they're
focusing their practice on America's but
Duke you imagine so doctors is like what
what market is about to [ __ ] it blow up
that we can get it at the ground level
blow up an anal not you know what I
don't know man I was just stick to the
kiddies spread wide open read them cheek
spread them as cakes god but yeah my fat
ass kqd cakes okay that's what the
doctors are safe you don't like the way
your booty cakes look and well it's not
my booty cakes doctor it's the creamy
feeling of ha ha ha ha they offer
everything from aesthetic procedures
like tag removal guess that's common
I've never I don't have any [ __ ]
butthole tags I have a few I've Levi's
hi oh yeah I have one that says medium
either another one return to sender I
wrote my name around mine in case I ever
got lost at camp if you find this
[ __ ] please return to cinemas mommy's
models I'm David for no you have
first-class postage that you don't do so
no I went with the cheap yeah
maybe all they also do bleaching anal
tightening Botox Botox agents in sex she
can't take a big old D is numb the
muscles you can handle that Big D is
that what it is yeah what the [ __ ] guys
cube one said Big D's in your ass too
bad for your health I don't know what
that was baby he really say that it's in
one of his songs check yourself before
you wreck yourself but he also put his
dick it's Jimmy runs deep said he'd put
her butt to sleep what's weird though is
any attack bill Mahr for saying things
that were inappropriate so it seems like
one once you make a song called [ __ ] the
police Jesus
anyhow I digress so Goldstein he says
you got this private practice going for
seven years in the office in New York
we're in LA he's out here in LA if
anyone wishes a public practice where
they do it along a sidewalk where
there's a window that you can go in and
ride now they do it Nick a community
room at the local library here for dr.
Goldsmith he's just at the computer over
there's a live demonstration he said
most of his clients are gay dudes how
does he know he just sounds like the way
gold seed just going ahead making some
slightly large tomji was talking to them
you guys are pretty open literally and
figuratively now do you think any guy
straight guys that are in there trying
to metrosexual up their butt holes for
their walks
I could see yeah yeah I'd shaved my
butthole around the sides and now I comb
hair over to the side
yeah pardon hipster haircut yeah it's a
Conor McGregor [ __ ] cut these dudes
are coming to me says whether you or no
both for aesthetic Liese
they want aesthetic is what it is he
also handles lots of procedures that are
not just about making ass is pretty
enough to eat off of this is what I said
Wow but uh he emphasized that aesthetic
Oh sir concerns can be chalked up to
undiagnosed medical problems he's
looking at symptoms of developed what's
going on internally but above his goals
he just trying to get some more business
yeah
it's trying to push his anal business he
said this can be from things like
hemorrhoids anal warts abscesses or
fistulas cracks from the but called
fissures these are caught usually
covered by insurance you got insurance
out there get your [ __ ] checked out
yeah
for a degrees I'm I get mine uh you know
make it look 10 years younger don't you
just put some alum on it
what's alum that stuff in Looney Tunes
they would like give people alum and
make their mouth shrink River ha ha ha
the sort of what's called it's like
really sour you saw you talking to Acme
FRA yeah I'm only in it for the advil I
do I buy all my rocket fuel duh
propulsive devices yeah from X I so wait
oh I remember that their mouth would
shrivel up yeah that's what it was
called alum yeah yeah it's like a really
paid a lot of attention it's a small
detail in Looney Tunes secret way have
you been watching them later Looney
Tunes you'll find them here on Nick lots
of stuff enough to make you sick I
thought you're gonna go do this uh this
is where it gets a little crazy because
dr. Goldstein I guess is second to none
and follow-up care
oh he's flexing in the butt make sure I
did Club up you're not far off put the
finger in there Oh in their butthole it
says so you usually experience a few
days of pain followed by followed by him
[ __ ] you with a few more days of a
few weeks of Winston deucing coups ooh
then that's probably the worst oh there
yeah but you're like look how it looks
it was worth it oh yeah I forgot you got
to take a dump
yeah Oh it'd be a perfect kind of fast
yeah cuz how the hell do a ton of
opioids you like well no [ __ ] coming up
but how do you stitch it up if you have
to stitch it up how the [ __ ] do you do
that without it heals back apparently
your go internal bag superfast you just
have to have like pure you don't that
take someone who gives you just diarrhea
which is [ __ ] cuz that will hurt they
get the wipe no wife bidet do the flush
of a white
bidet it but I might then get super
soaker yeah I give neighborhood kids
owes me off of the Super Soaker hey guys
don't square feet in the bullseye field
if your sub still on that Super Soaker I
saw running around with lat
yeah $85 a day hey you lemonade span
they doing it I need this yeah this will
only take five minutes
milky milky limit name this is around
the corner where the top plus you'll
love the view this is like a brand new
[ __ ]
I guarantee it you're gonna like the way
you get [ __ ] in the ass I guarantee it
anyone isn't sorry just write that on a
billboard dr. Goldstein my you're gonna
like well your blood looks I guarantee
during a series of the follow-up visit
dr. G's patients work with fingers toys
in blood plugs to make sure that
everything's safe come from a pain-free
when it comes to bedroom boy whose
fingers does the random guy hey let me
see your figures it's a real log finger
yeah it's games
but what would you do that would you be
the guy does the finger for save me 200
bucks a day you have to work like three
hours yeah do that everyone is yes like
a good [ __ ] it let's do an audiobook I
know it's just like I've ever did I was
trying to put push a button in some
weird robot hey what a hot you've got a
really clean you're under your
fingernail after your today's work think
they might work no how did you go bear
what if they request no gloves
nope interesting I do I do a girl - what
- a gynecologist and he he used no no
glove he [ __ ] stuff said sir will you
that girl know what I want to be killed
I knew did he bring in like a [ __ ]
tray and he's like ah take some time and
uh come back if it is a strap-on where
you go in there's like a [ __ ] there's
a unicorn yeah Donizetti's like alright
let's check him out here we go right let
me yeah hey let me taste the guarantee
you he's there watching them I think
he's doing it yeah I think he is doing
it I think he goes we'll know if it
worked if both of us come ha ha ha ha I
know I've done a good job but I squirt
much worse a Yanni massage of buttholes
Richard I don't know about gulp speeds
techniques anymore where the hell is
operation
what do you mean where is the office
yeah where is it at rage - Monica
Boulevard I would have said what I don't
know you're like ah yeah I've actually
worked out of a glory hole
you did your [ __ ] in there it vices
for those complaining of a loose hole
fixing a lot of these underlying
problems are naturally going to tighten
the anus loose oh he just farted
I reported a Jeff he did not back a
glove
no Mike sorry Zach but he did get his
ass over he's working the soundboard
says when you remove pieces from your it
says the anal PI is aware of ice is
really getting crazy so this is that's a
this is a real real medical term
according to the Adel PI the
circumference okay second juice tastes
great but it smells like [ __ ]
hey good help water 7805 I'm aware of
your windows filter the anal Venn
diagram it's not cooling it's warming oh
it's warming yonder good L could smell
it and then walked by it circumference
Naturals our booty shake your booty cake
moving pies oh what a delicious present
for a traveling how about some fresh ah
boutique a the ice could just melt some
of the top hey don't worry guys either
of you are thinking about butthole
surgery the incisions are internal so no
one's gonna see the scope oh good oh
yeah but they'll feel it if they put
your finger in no you're like that's
natural I was born with oh yeah
naturally Turtles I got the butt hole of
a bear trap my god enter I have a set
you to it enter he wrote for you gotta
be a pretty rare old risk
yeah very desperate abandon all hope ye
who enter here
ha ha ha ha well this is what your dick
before a drink oh that's nice yeah you
have a Matt Bevin Matt I've look too bad
it'll welcome Matt Oh tom
sounds problems he was too tight for
bottoming anymore so goldstein anymore
Oh Gulf you got tighter do you know he
was too tight from the previous position
for a toe anymore yeah I went to
Goldstein the master of the butthole
it's what he's known in the medical
world yeah that's what his card says
they on the safecracker yeah
he puts on us he puts on a draws my
monocle look at a diamond and he goes
very close to your bud place and he
performed a surgical dilation to open
Tom up and slightly widen that anal
canal tom says I in quotes I can take a
small to average size penis now so it's
not fully bad Malta average Jesus well
my life before that I think large to
extra second I can only take a dog dick
it's a puppy from a pumper you only take
a horse Pope initially funny though
man he said I used to be able to take a
wrist size [ __ ] before my father's eyes
[ __ ] yes I he said is he finding these
guys with risk so nobody out there with
a wrist size can never be wrist size Cox
calm I just checked it out just to see
if I was on there but it's really short
like two inches long but it's let me do
it but you a big rest with me I know but
I'm like my there's time you look at all
of our wrists look at that okay we need
your bill dearest put your hands around
your wrist what there's a home they
could be that back thick few minds like
that minds like that let's priests I
mean yeah but close it up a little bit
maybe he's at this [ __ ] I think now
I'm thinking Mike yeah that's a big
sense man I think that's like a beer
keys right but I mean you could barely
fit that in your pants
old Tom takes those bracelet dicks just
[ __ ] bagel maybe he was taken like
three of them in like putting electrical
tape around them
Tamagotchi livestrong oh well ok because
of that now the inside they say doc used
for trapping [ __ ] together put your pot
anymore looks like he's before breast
cancer is this a lot of coffee
tom he knew that that would that quote
would really set people off he said I
was pretty talented back there I think
that good saying yeah that first doctor
really really [ __ ] up his but he did
it will actually did too good of a job
so here's the thing I said about Botox
for people having trouble just bottoming
in general goldstein offers anal Botox
which paralyzes the sphincter muscles
makes it easier to take something a
little bit
easier to tear apart yeah like having
trouble taking that huge D let's
paralyze those muscles then they can't
do anything to stop it
dude you I would have you're having out
of control oh no if you've no Cano
feeling and you're as well you might be
shooting out of withdrawal maybe he does
it right before they're about to get
[ __ ] by a giant penis music oh by the
way will you inject my [ __ ] with this
and paralyzes the muscles because you've
got so big if it's a compliment
whoa looks like somebody's going to need
an injection and not just that beef
injection I'm going to need you to
paralyze the muscles of my record in
order for me to accommodate your wrist
size penis also is it is it an
average-sized penis not easiest to find
maybe I mean unless you're literally
just talking for huge Tom's one is a
size Queen he was wrist size only this
size to capsule let me see we see the
picture size caps I wish I could bicep
si sighs I used to love feeling a man's
penis deltoids flexing inside but my ass
yeah yeah what do you know what do you
like down there torsos your nose the
thickness of a parking meter telephone
poles I've I like ya Pierre can it's
lame I'm cute I'm a 2-liter man hey give
me a gallon of milk size same shape with
a handle I think when you paralyze those
muscles anything's possible you
paralyzed them from the neck down to
waist they give you a little wheelchair
for your puzzle after that yeah you're
going to beat it after that after that's
[ __ ] you're never going to walk again
because you don't know how bad guy yeah
where's object oh my god okay what would
have to be wrong with your hands
although to go ahead and get not one
Syria but two surgeries on your butt
you're [ __ ] painful that is yeah
doesn't it but then again if you're
taking the razor sighs and that's just
and that's your sexual though that's
you're saying that it seems like you
want to take no no I think I'd be like
well something tells me those tomji got
in trouble off not taking care of his
toys parents like you gonna treat your
nerf boomerang
one day you're going to be getting your
[ __ ] come by Goldstein
if you can't put your toys up if you
keep breaking your toys and what's gonna
happen I'm sure his father said that
more than one golf see noticed the
practice starting to really boom five
years ago he said in case you start
asking for more lickable playable holes
i want to be its office lickable
playable what the drilling new all this
isn't having a mini golf course it is
candy everywhere like a little playable
hole to the west favorite mini golf you
can eat the kids like a woman walter
kaufmann ago it's not very fun number
for anyone to lick immense come on down
little playable we have a limos long ago
the go karts are require a rough what do
you get when you tear your ass
Oh golf eat if you're listening we can
do seems commercials whatever you need
we're here for you man go 90% of
goldstein business is now in jesus what
we also doing in addition to that before
head my exam she was also harder to
rejuvenate is my exam oh yeah he was
orthodontist and a natal rejuvenates you
did i exams his conjunctivitis race oh
yeah oh wait we should wipe that down we
were just looking at with that before
they're done accidentally put braces on
this guy's [ __ ] he's like the [ __ ]
test is click the button what do you see
an [ __ ] bottle it was great
there's some other dude who was a piece
of colon and rectal surgeon based in
Southern California
he said you started paying attention to
the stuff 2009 he says a full fifth of
his practice is anal goddamn what's
going on with people with like that
unhappy with their [ __ ] his doctor
said when I started practicing some of
my proctology patients were embarrassed
and they would ask if I could make it
look nice and chuckle but now wait nice
and make the [ __ ] chuckle no they
make it look at I said chuckle
okay we're chuckling at the comment like
oh hey if you can't why don't you make
my ass look nice and chuckle it but he
said now it's become a reality
kids certainly have buddies dreams go on
with a glove man there's a problem
though ain't a rejuve it's not being
it's not taught in med school so you get
a really these guys were the ninety
Rodya gotta go you're close that
butthole time with the guy the second
doctor said he's established some of his
own protocols which is it's risky
especially around a toe bleaching and
techniques to reduce scarring so he's I
guess the first guy must have been
scarred to shoot so we're at like I've
gotten better so it's like the early
days of hair plugs the one-legged ten
years and he look terrible it's like the
iPhone you may not want to get that to
the first right when it comes out you
want to wait till some of these guys are
learning on their own on the job one job
training Tommy a straining there's a
DeVry commercial about that what uh
Adel I had no nation training I worked
at a used car parts before then I went
to DeVry now my parents garage when the
secretary Drudge this gets technical
about like what he does all surgeries
through a glory hole this fixes what do
you guys think this costs for tightening
three two thousand six thousand
application fifteen thousand it's
usually run G between 1500 and 2500 oh
Jesus Christ the better ability just
aesthetic procedures Oh what if I wanted
to it can accommodate your a writ of
size wieners or elective and no
insurance because they're elective
that's just for aesthetics what about an
elephant if they said insurance comes
Wiener what's that oh yeah they'll give
me the elephant hole yeah oh you like
bigger hole yeah cause I can give the
bigger they say the most common
complains that they've been in a
relationship with a partner that may
have been larger and they feel that
they're stretched inside and out
and that they can't give the pleasure to
the partner they're currently with can
they just get when you go from
extra-large to like a smedium and then
this medium is like a DM I can't fit I
can't fit here
can you I can they just put a stick if
the dick don't fit we must quit
MC Hammer would disagree with proper
that I just thought this Asian guy died
I don't know where they mention think he
talked about techniques he sees a lot of
patients from parts of the Midwest of
the south now the asian guy he has his
butthole turn from sideways to strange
yeah he did that and you got it opened
up they put a stick in there to prop it
open he did that himself in the mirror
he said Midwest and South is an open
market because there aren't a lot of
nearby doctors comfortable handling
sensitive topics wait you're talking
about your butt okay get out of it was
an Asian doctor me Chinese me play fast
me be surgery on your head
that's a slogan let's go born in Alabama
what have you playing so fast me Chinese
have no rash let me help tighten your
gash for the winning Chinese maybe - let
me put finger in your ass shave me help
you people in stitches are you boy by
the way if it's not Chinese were really
out of life she's Korean
these are hominid cities me play trick
me no longer take that's a big trick SP
trick
you Chinese to be real nice we couldn't
let you take dick wrist side oh I'm sure
would really use for their business it I
can [ __ ] was great haha that's what my
oh my god every willing to admit this
they stole from you could take him to
take them we don't want to we wanted
answer to that man was okay another one
of these doctors is gay himself and you
said that having a team with greater
understanding of your your what you're
going through as a patient is important
a gay male wants to talk to a gay male
about this oh yeah it's a good point
like I've gone to women doctors above my
dingus yeah they're like you know if you
ever get that feeling you know your feed
with your dick they're like yeah I'm
doing you're talking about I gotta go
this is a profession ridiculous
Goldstein is gay himself married two
kids he feels the same I don't know how
you can be interim provide the type of
service whatever golfing talking is me
be gay me know just what to say grammar
needs work but isn't the messages are
all right on point I go to him if I
needed he Goldstein says hetero doctors
he does not think and provide this type
of you this is the kind of culture we're
now living in look like we can't even go
to Ed Road like to go to a hetero doctor
doing anal surgery at gay men it's
probably gonna be very frowned upon in
the next ten years cultural
appropriation
yeah like a balloon and you know surgery
I don't know procreate thing what did he
know he's never taken a wrist size [ __ ]
yeah do you think a high five they dock
recites Cajun guy called secrety told at
the convention at some Howard Johnson's
and Jansen for [ __ ] anal rejuvenation
doctors they Goldstein says sometimes
clients problems I don't know why you
say client isn't a patient anyway
bottoming doesn't need surgical
intervention
they just need coaching on how to do
oh man from doctor to sex coach just
like that
get in there slugger he says things like
take this yeah look at coach let me see
let's see what you're doing let me put
it like a football coach get taken d
dammit
listen take both knees I put my head
back boy pants down dammit
wait it feels fine yeah that's why we
need to start with burpees you need to
go out to here you need to take those
Dixie's drove over your ass I don't care
damn it crying if you scramble all the
way in you're at your [ __ ]
half-hearted that's the problem citizen
you're all in your [ __ ] you're not
using it user to lose it goddamn it
you got five yards left and you go for
the punt no you turn over your spread to
change have you taken up here while
you're here let me paralyzed those
muscle just in case Jesus Christ
maybe with maybe we can hit an anal
coaching coach you got a paralyzed my
muscles I can't take a dick that me what
if it's just yelling at your [ __ ]
look at you you can see your weight
Jersey you're five foot nothing
yeah diameters a hundred yep they're
heard this long puddinin' coach Fredi
before the one of these docs says he
thinks there should be less stigma deal
with the ass one of his offices in West
Hollywood
Shanker if we want to go there it's not
far from the studio let's go get a
consultation he says we'll have a lot of
gay patients this guy could be hetero I
don't know said many tell me I'm the
best gay friendly doctor in West
Hollywood
how sad is that you still need a
category that's gay friendly in West
Hollywood that is a sad indictment on
the rest of the country whoa nobody said
yeah dr. marell she's actor Moreau yeah
and his island of dr. Moreau silent yeah
he come to my Island be so Jaguar teeth
in the people pass all look at this one
that I've created here there's a hand
that will reach out and actually pull
the Wiener inside this here's a monkey's
paw
this dude the dude who was named I think
in his article does a portion I skipped
he's a walking testament to the mean Ojo
patient doctor what he said people know
where I work if I'm asked up somewhere
it needs to look good I look like I did
a porn star let's get the portion but
there's the ahh so listen if you want
your ass worked on ya gave you some good
I'll turn some good and don't be ashamed
of it there's no stigma
I guess anymore to it everybody's doing
it let's segue into there's a new kind
of sex out there gentlemen what is it
called there's no protection no sorry
Michael I clicked on the wrong thing but
this is the ultimate present that O'Neal
needs in his life
Oh China is coming out of China they're
always ahead of us and they're not
always but sometimes there's a craze
taking over Chinese kids would learn
like it O'Neal's gonna love it okay
toothpick crotch yeah oh good nails in
them oh look at that yeah they don't
think they can break beer bottles people
poop immediately yes do you like idols
and nails in them yeah I used to do that
you know what they said those rubber
bullets reviewer I would put tacks in
the end of them we would shoot him they
sticking your legs when gremlins 2 came
out we would get the same yeah the new
batch from the gremlins 2 and make the
bow and arrows with them and ya can
think switch shoot you could shoot a
pencil and get it into somebody really
dude I have got so these are for sale
right now China well you can get them
here if they're for sale China they're
sale everywhere yeah this is a new
fidget spinner generate of the violent
or viable generation I love it I thought
you would these that says that some
parents are anxious to really break a
beer bottle yeah it said that some
parents aren't check out the Instagram
videos man I'm going to the parents want
them banned because they think a young
child can get blinded or worse they're
selling online and shops as little as
7u1 that's a dollar oh [ __ ] Jesus
toothpick crossbows were originally
designed to shoot toothpicks and
probably clean your teeth they shoot
this thick in between my third my bike
up it but if swapped out for needles
they're potent enough to crack glass
said the Sheng oh yeah needles in there
that shop only found about its exact
lunch Evan gallbladder problems I'd be
fatal
rejuvenation do these shop owners can't
keep them in stock they said they're
struggling to meet the man Oh what
they're taking off man if you're maybe
all head crap if they have kids in your
class you dupe exactly yeah you gotta
fire back no one needs to build little
shields why they get he big shields you
want to bet the box
nice little shield business never takes
off I think I know stupid this is also a
frisbee store I'd wear a career of the
Jabar god dude you [ __ ] law really
wear goggles type of tomfoolery is going
on at China I mean I the idea of getting
hit with a toothpick in the eyeball or
in a doll church what coming Nield you
to the back type III shoot toothpick
your tighty Big O and a threat he
pointed it away imported Zack Zack yeah
why's that here unlock the door he came
in the window he brought us a bunch of
fidgets spinners in the hood crossbows
oh cool yeah and there was new naked eye
chicken nachos from Taco Bell those are
called naked chicken nacho you had a
naked chicken chalupa from Taco Bell he
was discontinued but it was really I
haven't been at Taco Bell in probably 20
years wait so they just continued I just
had one last night they have I think it
might have been old stock I have vampa
nachos now you can buy them on the
street black market Jesus you have to
know whose is it dumped it yeah you got
to go yeah go ahead
I found one of my ass after I left his
office do these things can fire to
distance more than 20 meters 65 feet
Jesus just like a sniper and shoot iron
nails if you want to go more hardcore
than I like they're giving you all the
deadly stuff I probably put exactly
enough for our to walk or do that we're
going to tell you how you considered out
your nails the shockingly the primary
people getting these are middle school
children very shocking it a kid they
some quotes that it's powerful enough to
puncture a balloon and pierce cardboard
powerful enough to bugs are
balloon in when it's swap that's the
toothpick so is the ground when it's
swapped for a metal needle becomes a
dangerous weapon no man
cops in Chengdu major city in China
Southwest beautiful there this time of
year James behavior quarterly stop sales
of the product and concerned parents one
a government ban due to I don't get it
man I love it I think it's great how
many kids have lost eyes I want some
statistics someone died in a cinnamon
challenge one parents I wrote on Weibo
China's fake Twitter hurry up and ban on
pupils do not understand if you're
shooting people for fun it will cause
accidents as opposed to what were they
supposed to be shooting for sport like
what is the other alternative everything
for study should be I had a guy try to
shoot an apple off my head no one right
into my forehead but it felt good
because it was an acupuncture always
acupuncture needle yeah why don't they
just do it an acupuncture why don't they
shoot the acupuncture needles into
people across both now I got a s'more a
s'more thing what do you call the s'more
spear I got a s'more spear shotgun she
got this okay like I know what you're
talking about I want one why don't you
put one of those in the tiny crossbow
someone needs to let's go to China with
potato guns and you speak just it's just
the Battle of the shittiest equipment
contra make like a tennis ball gun what
do you want to go in there it is denim
potato as a super similar yeah but I the
potato gun can be way more powerful they
make the hair spray that you can use for
the potato guns still though we used to
just use the lighter fluid we use hair
spray my buddy blasted light he
shattered my taillight when he shot my
truck with one I'm sure he didn't take
that well no I was pissed
you don't hit you don't handle car
damage very well at all just blew it
just shred it destroyed it they they
wrote an article about that on Jalopnik
did they might be losing weight to LA in
1994 blacks or the fast again I named
O'Neal listen let's do a look back in
history what happened
thank you 13 mm 18 anymore now trace of
Indiana and his pale light shoutout I
could dude the potato good but you know
what the tennis ball gun was was
actually not that it wouldn't hurt you
that bad
hey no guns are way more dangerous kill
a duck with it yeah you can get fokin
from somewhere here sorry
absolutely this is very very specific
and could about anything kill a duck
it's not cuz allegedly chosen for a
specific dinner
my cousins shoot a duck Oh sky with
alleged Jesus a real sniper with the
potato gallantly I think he was only
eight over using russets the purple ones
she knows it purple which is harder so
sometimes Oh a little small testicle
sometimes the tennis ball would catch on
fires when it shot out even better and
you see what are the small potatoes
called
oh yeah tato fingerlings yeah if you put
a bunch of fingerlings in there it's
like a it's like a box of buckshot
how many uh happy 100 to you how many
finger a little static they're having
some sound issues let's go around and
say how many fingerlings we could take
in our [ __ ]
I can take a risk how much how are they
putting them in there one at a time if
it's one at a time I could probably take
ten of them I could take a 20 pound bag
I can take a fist-sized if it's any
measure potatoes yeah I could if I could
take like a UH a diesel truck exhaust
pipe if I'm going to be totally honest I
could take a traffic cones worth of
copper bottom top of the quarter box
starts at the stop again to them that's
like I like your techniques though you
know case call the Quackenbush a booty
cakes no like that you're like this
doughnut hole like a shape like it wait
what we always forget the stupid [ __ ] on
here then people write in we would feel
so saving the inscription again what are
you talking about why is that rockin
baby the inscription
I don't think this is pretty tiny me
show you encryption Sammy inscription uh
it's a me inscription wait this is the
Chinese character that I was doing my
dear show that couple months ago that
guys wrote in and complain what about a
show what a show called unplug what do
you show quit book oh the answer to it
show no where can they find your patreon
patreon.com
slash the answer to it show support them
guys yeah it's like I believe it's
French French dessert they look like
munchkins or doughnut holes where we
call them and they're built in like this
configuration of a cone there's like
some sort of frosting that holds them
all together oh I know it's a crock and
Bush that was gone rocket Bush pocket
rocket Bush we asked that we couldn't
figure out what GBH was on Twitter and
people like negative people wrote into
it like if you know what I said like to
be honest you idiot wait we didn't I
didn't know both of us okay I will
remember to be decided outside that's
what it was - exactly another tough
butthole I thought it was to be Hasidic
it would be sinning it was a juice Jew
comment you guys ready for the new
sexual trend that I teased you with and
open up the toothpick length plan yeah I
thought it was shooting the toothpicks
into your wiener is this from far out
dad barb says she's got to get it all
just the last one yeah that part is a
fresh batch of barb fresh rhubarb pie
and it's a developer Ebola rhubarb pie
Gary yeah they're here man it's at a
high rate a nice slice of Barbara's
[ __ ] back rhubarb pie yeah you playing
at the Greek theater oh I remember on
autumn morning when I was looking to
skin tags on a woman's ass oh I need to
say dr. gall my good friend dr. Golding
a good friend dr. Goldstein was fiddling
about around my anus trying different
butt plug make sure the Thursday dr.
Gould stayed just opened up an office in
Lake Wobegon and the butt holes have
never looked better
where the woman's butt holes are tied in
the men's are loose Mitch I be like Gary
Keeler woman me go feel her yeah we're
get we're getting Gary Q to the Greek be
a great sequel to Greek because he's
losing his mind watch me a lot allegedly
Oh has anybody she the Greek Theatre
I'll bet he I'm in Los Feliz I can't
find my way to the Greek I need a gyro
just behind there in the street I ate a
sandwich are you to sandwich from a man
who gave me the sandwich he told me he
had ejaculated semen inside of it that
reminds me of a poem today from the
Irish poet mcdr gerber verse Wow pretty
burger burger the best what a my
favorite a happy Holi
this one's called but givers delight
that like set the record so it's a
German writer haha probably one of the
most famous burger burger boats a hotel
room lobby dress no fridge great opening
my big burger burger as usual visual
style strange stains paint the wall of
very nice strange tongues paint my balls
that I do here is your tongue brushing
here I come this studies me like Wallace
meals are like balls I feel like even
though red rhythm we Chinese we need
rhythm oh it's a good one Oh get ready
to learn about new sex if real sex not
the HBO show but it's like actual
literal that's here literal sex is lame
for you I guess something's gonna take
me a phone call this is from the barb
found this via New York Post originally
published on the Sun both classy yes
people becoming in publications this is
called astral
x-naught [ __ ] sex ads probably 1s in
that astral sex 1s the new sex trend
something [ __ ] all right
the unusual trend is to do all of this
have sexual intercourse via astral
projection not happen which is actual
notify having an out-of-body experience
of over you while you're out of your
body you [ __ ] you five so it's a beaut
don't worry this is they keep it a nice
cool spell some people believe is a new
form of abstinence oh yeah you can lose
your astral virginity but that pussy's
pristine Oh Mike yeah some people
believe that the soul is able to
consciously travel outside the body
those people are lunatics an argument
reinforced and said by recent scientific
findings which they do not quote just a
fad that's it
well looks like by the way but if my
bill science magazines and I think if
Mike Rogers at his garage doctor go
seems like by the way in astral
projections if I repair your [ __ ]
there it'll be unbelievable be cheaper
because I won't really different well if
you were just doing astral projections
you wouldn't have so many [ __ ]
rejections hello the this article says
you may even had an out-of-body
experience yourself with astral
projection believed to be most common
how many people had an out-of-body
experience anybody in this room ever
have an out-of-body experience for hi
one time on edibles I had an out-of-body
experience what happened it's all costs
floating above my body did you see your
body below it's on my shoulders but like
I don't know if that's just me imagining
did you go down and check out your bulb
of your undercarriage I did did you [ __ ]
any other spirits I flex my own body
what your natural masturbate against my
when you woke up I raised myself when I
think about myself I rape myself dude
maybe I should do that instead of
waiting for a time machine to go back
and suck my own dick if you're gonna do
astral projection astral projection 69
and who fell 69 walkathon that I could
see the projection what hey I don't know
what I do
the guy's my projection this is my soul
it's my film projection comes out of
your dick hole like a genie like there's
like a lot of video so you legitimately
had that I had what do you think he was
on drugs so it's hard to say you know it
kind of that's the only time I thought
that muddies the experiment yeah
but they say when you're when you just
wake up you can oh I've had sleeping and
being awake they think even an astral
peregrination that's what I'm seeing
when I sometimes I get out of bed but
you see in your people are tethered so
you can [ __ ] like this dude yeah no I
well yeah just myself I'll just be
jerking off but what's weird though well
you have to have someone else that also
does it at the same time they say for
some these feelings create the sensation
or some for no puppy that's never
happened it says of flying or falling I
got to be joking away real quick you
guys want me to be jolted awake but who
hasn't had the dream where you're
falling and then you wake up that's a
house that an astral projection which is
just a dream of [ __ ] [ __ ] projects
or what a [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
perfect dreaming of falling dude this is
it they can't do this this is an
impossibility so Steve G Jones not Steve
Jones of the sex pistol it's not the
other G guy Kenny G Oh Steve G from the
in preview yeah Tom G it's a table G ah
he's related to him is this the same guy
it's not because Jesus guys middle name
goddamn not G love and the special sauce
remember though yeah this guy Steve G
Jones has between the worst jobs ever
heard he's an astral projection
specialist how did that degree good
thing he specialized literally how do
you how do you earn that title I'm gonna
say you just bestow it upon yourself
it's a good point
he actually believes that it's possible
to train yourself to have these
out-of-body experiences whenever you
want how do you treat yourself I'm
assuming you have to pay dr. Steve oh we
got a secret probably and astral sex
combines is perfectly innocent feeling
with sex to create intimate moments
which are truly out of this world
according to the article so do you come
in your pants when you wake up have you
already come in your pants like you're
basically having a sex dream is that
isn't that what you're doing yeah
because I guess dr. Steve Jones
they now cause an astral sex guru he
believes that when two people are having
an out-of-body sex they're not actually
having a physical moment yeah no [ __ ]
how's that yeah we get it what would we
get I'm not especially but I understand
that [ __ ] no [ __ ] you [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] are you talking about we were
perfectly clicker on that yeah okay big
bonfire for King Shan you have a
foursome where you're [ __ ] with this
woman take a lot of Pro astral
projections and then your spirits are
also [ __ ] in the sky wherever they
[ __ ] on the ceiling
dude southern belle this is just like
when you have a wet dream when you're
just dreaming about [ __ ] that's but I
don't think it's anything more than that
is a woman dreaming about it yeah
probably not the woman that you hear
[ __ ] in your dream the dream rape
[Music]
[Laughter]
only way that I should hate to work as
an actual astral projection to the movie
theater anything I wish is an [ __ ]
projection really hey just don't worry
yeah you scream to people hey shut the
[ __ ] up I thought you were projecting
the movie yeah but he was an ass though
I thought you were an [ __ ] the
projected movie [ __ ] projection well
that's the [ __ ] up in there and watch
The Matrix ounds like Fran lilacs is
working to projector so do you believe
by the way if anyone's going to believe
of this it might be you know and this is
coming from a guy who tried to meditate
myself to orgasm one time listening to
binaural beat pornography or like orgasm
inducing beat how'd it go for you would
you put the headphones on your neck Oh
or was it be hoarse better job I was
afraid if I put the headphones on my
dick then wrapped my hands around the
headphone jacks up and down working
because they were right when was this
by Jove he's got it he's got it when was
this and how many weeks of your time a
few years ago maybe three or four years
ago and I did it for about 45 minutes
and five minutes I think the only thing
I got was it got a little bit hard a
little pre come a little bit of urine
what I
what's that what was it cold is a
binaural beat beat oh is that I've had
that in my salad dude it I so yeah
that's ridiculous unless the headphones
come and they're shaped like a vagina
it's said in the UT unless the
headphones on a woman's ears and she's
[ __ ] what if that happened you come
to the lady come she goes okay put these
oughta meditate that'll suck your dick
it would be kind of hot you know would
be hot oh this would be great this
whether you have you if you're getting a
[ __ ] from a chick and she's recorded
dirty talk of her voice because that's
one of the worst things the only bad
thing about getting a [ __ ] is there's
no dirty bed silence there's a dead
silence of the sound that's not bad I
like the sucking noises farts yeah yeah
yeah
thank your Xebec anti show appreciation
for the [ __ ] okay one of us either go
to dr. Cole you know how cars now how
they pump in the exhaust note through
the speakers yeah they do that so that
could I do the sucking sound
I haven't amplified please I would
speaker it's a real firecracker yeah
it's real and imagine if a girl was
sucking your dick and she put okay I'm
there
yeah who was their names on you what's
her name oh it's Hilda okay she recorded
all this stuff Oh beautiful Swedish yeah
it's sooo so she recorded all this dirty
talking parts scene record the dirty
talk of her and like wouldn't that be
great wouldn't it be great oh [ __ ] god
damnit so angry man what if she just
returned to do that for a chick I would
100% do that I would 100% record like a
dirty man me talk he got realization to
it I'm licking her [ __ ] she's loving it
you need a girl ever [ __ ] do some
[ __ ] like that but these ocarina [ __ ]
easier to take this a quick break and be
like hey you plug in a horrible [ __ ]
real good this is the next tape of the
new smoke generation yeah dude what if
it was just but then they could use it
with a new boyfriend a girlfriend and
that would be
dad because like I put so much time and
effort into that dirty talk album what
if you get celebrity voices your
favorite celebrity voice to record dirty
are you doing up there can you suck in
me I'm sucking you off big but it's just
impression doing your breakfast you got
it
keep licking didn't I do that did I suck
your dick uh yeah this was a Garrison
Keillor and future's cool [ __ ] though
Tim Allen
I like Wow scoob's I'm sucking a dick
what's the deal with this blow job ya
dick suck exit stage one hey girl I
think we're onto a new business model
let's all farts beware there ha there's
a lot of dicks in this picnic basket
we're doing sex cording dot-com uh so
yeah that would be a good idea are you
pulling everyone in there that's when he
come yeah well I don't do you think I
think more men would be into this in
women yes I don't think women want any
of this now women love dirty talk
they do love dirty talk but they it's so
focused on like yeah you [ __ ] you love
this you dirty [ __ ] what's wrong with
that what do you what do you want
oh I'm cutting cherry tomatoes and
they're so [ __ ] juicy well yeah I
don't want you you are the artists the
water correct rest is so crisp oh yeah
you are a gorgeous female you are one
gorgeous female boy are you pretty keep
inter coursing my penis yes
you bring me to orgasm satisfyingly
rogue you are very confident in what you
do
your vaginal walls are adequate for
working my dick towards ejaculation
I would like saliva to fly out of your
mouth onto my heart penis and would I
give you would you hit my quarterly
performance review it will be positive
so you're hypnotizing hor [ __ ] off while
you're eating a chart with excellent
sexual performance right now
keep it up needs improvement in all
other areas yeah but it's an excellent
unsexual that's the person that I really
like you I'm not a big audio guy I
wouldn't really care for it or more
video yeah I like both man I'm uh listen
to audio stories and be tough to I have
to see like I got to have that ass
propped up I got to be able to play with
it I got a real play with things be of
choice but now that is true yeah I'd
like you put my Lincoln Logs right over
here so I can read them while you're
sucking my dick you passed the Koosh
ball
Ryan what is that oh I got like a couple
Lego men fighting each other on top of
your back actually would be great Ryan
put this [ __ ] toothpick like what is
that oh it's a paddle in a ball put on a
rubber band that I've employed then you
spank over the others yeah are you
massaging me now I'm running to hot
wheels up and down your spine
great track let me go get yourself
checked for scoliosis and speaking of
too fast too furious
he must nut [ __ ] how's entertaining is
here tom I should be I want to have
sexual intercourse while I jump on a
trampoline and you can't be a good way
to break your dick you can't but you
can't learn it's a good way to break
your growth plates to come out of the
[ __ ] you can't come out you have a VCR
baby really better what's that saniti
it's my thing but you know my nightmare
is breaking my dick on a trampoline
while [ __ ] my trampoline face do you
think
you Crenn you think you could hold so
you're holding her legs are wrapped
around your insider could you do a flip
on a trip leave like that we know what
they say you tried it if they died
terrible I know you never turn a flip on
a trampoline inside of a [ __ ] down the
bush man worth listen how hard this
Steve Jones is selling people on his
[ __ ] I have further objection I say
if DeWitt doesn't buy it to it then I
don't fish I'm gonna have a lot of
trouble get people to come to a seminar
where it is guide him to come in this
come at all I see this boy like did you
come and everyone's lying there like I
think I came yeah definitely yeah oh
look look up look at this shirt I've
talked to everybody in this room
actually you're all a bunch of extra
you're going to astral jail that was
actually how dare you way she's not hate
the ancient office oh my god but her
astral projection holy 12
you said astral sack he's got the spirit
of a wolf so is the bestiality now I
have to go to jail oh man yeah no it's
not it's legal in most states
this was ECL yeah with what state did
you ask your projector would you [ __ ]
them yeah well you had a save date of
unconsciousness you're clean identify
first
hey I just got it yeah before we go out
until today with the 69 oh man I miss
doing this with you boy [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] sack leads to people poured it
out took a little will see you baggie to
our group but we're there gentlemen
episode 100 and they wanna [ __ ] astral
projection style manual done it's all
focused and see if we keep [ __ ] we
cannot come on what are your booty cakes
when I first accompanied you guys I'm
out of my body ah are you such a nice
body to body
I feel spirit oh you were a first Easter
g-string
what kind of further you're sweaty it's
gopher Gover on the back beer for on oh
I got a raccoon tail condom no yeah your
dicks inside of it yeah yeah it's cool
alright so this side of sex at least
people sold me gang this guy's is
there's gonna make a living he said
there's a big fan take a living this is
where he's trying to rope what are we
all doing wrong in Pacifica living off
this horseshit this is where your ropes
in that results in no procreation no
STDs no practice and no sex at night and
no good time two types of safe sex until
flex an astral projection you can't
knock the but there's three a's
abstinence anal and astral projection is
the best if you were painted like that
smell dating a teacher sleep it's like
how you know you remember it it's like
it's a triple aid of safety you know
when your car breaks at a culture bleh
we'll think about what your [ __ ]
triple-a anal
first because it feels the best definite
third cause it's badass hope ridiculous
if you're damn [ __ ] siffredi other
already if you're already practicing
abstinence go ahead and try astral
projecting you might as well give this a
shower in the list
not gonna be any bigger of a nerd what
do you have to lose it is insane
I also lose not your virginity
it says the star heading the paper in
England wait oh no Steve explains and
Steve G Jones astral sex specialist
he's actual sex specialist yeah he we've
got a job we do in the field yeah and I
want to be an astral sex physical
specialist yeah who thought episode 100
would be so anal you talking anal like
yeah there's so much angle we're all OCD
oh you mean uh got it he said Steve
explained feedback is very important
during sexual intercourse that sometimes
lost in the physical world what the put
in the answer what that's our world but
you're just [ __ ] talking God but alas
the world feedback is automatic because
you're seeing their soul oh my god does
the soul have big tits that's what's
good yeah yeah this all has big tits and
then you put your ear so in between them
move your soul of it down I gotta make
it I'm super bad she's brown dude I
don't
I gotta become I don't believe this
everybody you're not gonna try this
so you're those minded of you I know
what does he think do you think it's
disrespectful if you spin on a Souls
[ __ ]
no you thinks it's good recommends it
what depends you can see their soul so
the here to see their soul in a like you
so what does this old look like it look
like a woman does it look like a man and
that's when you wanted to lose members
it will Chamberlain [ __ ] over 18
million women astrally physically he had
25 do we really have too much time on
our hands as a society we're like let's
find different ways to [ __ ] oh here's
what what it doesn't exist the world
a mysterious fake world where we could
hover above our bodies it's [ __ ] each
other the world XY that STDs would make
life worth living your life weird I
begin something here you live it on the
edge live it albeit you can't help
yourself from
Oh miss O'Neill there's something wrong
with the world today but but hold it
ain't it Andrew this is good news for
you this are the paper they said [ __ ]
stacks can result in a deeper connection
than regular sex so take that regular
sex and can be achieved while
masturbating okay well is that good for
me I don't know so I think you think we
made a joke about you masturbating
astrally but I think it was I don't know
I lost it
well I did and didn't work if you guys
want to try this believer suggest you
should lie down and relax until the
point where you're in a meditative state
then in the moment try imagining that
you're slowly sitting up and then
visualize yourself leaving your body oh
I just did okay a big boy enter the
astral plane we should have an airline
called the astral plane I did - I did -
and there's a bunch of hot chicks from
heaven they're coming wait yeah wait I
begin this apartment building and we've
another code wait a second Zach lunch is
sold yeah he'd be the turkey leg in the
corner and he's jerk of it get him out
of here check into Turkey
it's you're into turkey and all oh
that's not a turkey leg it's a Turkey's
dick that's a turkey cleared clothes if
you like my friend it's one of the
stupidest things I've ever heard of my
life but a little sex it's worse than
the honey massage yeah cause it leave
that physical contact
this is [ __ ] insane just God do you
want to hear something else insane you
know I asked will project for employment
really didn't ask to employment and we
found employment where do you catch
those actual checks advanced you'll
check Cassie plate we Chinese we need
sex we ask from projecting pivots a
beautiful voice but I'll take it
the judges will take judges okay he's
not I got point it was it but it was a
split decision it wasn't unanimous this
is from a listener called Hieronymous
lush I don't know what that means but
hieronymus love yeah this is from The
Telegraph another
English yeah a lot of good articles I'll
tell you that they're on top of their
game written by Charlotte watch this you
guys are fans of her work him there's a
new trend I guess this is a 38 year old
woman named Sophie Tanner Sophie Tucker
no relation to Danny Tanner full house
which we sang the theme song to earlier
she celebrated her second wedding
anniversary on Tuesday there were none
of usual trappings no flowers or blah
blah that [ __ ] it's not that the
other half is like a deadbeat but that
on May 16 2015 when the PR consultant
took took her vows on the steps of
Brighton's Unitarian Church the person
she Swart cherish for eternity was
herself oh yeah I've seen this bullsháá
she married herself new trend of self
marriage how narcissistic is that
[ __ ] she wanted to protect and hold
and whatever else her so oh it's a
uniform of ceremony for this she didn't
wait till she divorces herself yeah
that's a tough one
yeah in the UH would you I mean if you
get someone someone ever married
themselves a I wouldn't go to I would
not give you a present oh wow really I
wouldn't be what I guess is happening no
she vited people yes I give her a
present I would kick her panel I would
kick her in the tip divorce proceedings
yeah when she put this [ __ ] woman
over herself on top look Kate who walks
her down the aisle
who she goes down once with her she
actually projects herself walking it a
woman dressed up like her I don't dude I
would run up punch her in the titties
and then leave
what a waste getting it up I'm inviting
him to do something like if you want to
do this and just do it on your losing
time these are pure [ __ ] friends if
you know a person that's like this if
you're an [ __ ] too that's true you're
all out of fear like this is great what
if you came to my wedding when I buried
myself what if you're related to them
though it's not your front going okay I
would go for family member buried
themselves and I go [ __ ] you I wouldn't
go this with my dog's animecon you're
ridiculous my mom or dad did I
definitely wouldn't [ __ ] go are you
kidding me rather than marry an animal I
would go if they're a pickle hey I'm
marrying a donkey I go yeah
gotta go see that hey Tristan I'm gonna
ride it yeah you gonna [ __ ] is this a
donkey that you always had your backyard
or a new one because I ain't myself no
one was looking I stick you give you
when I think about you I marry myself I
don't want no no oh no oh no hey my dude
man or woman you do this here a huge
[ __ ] just be single you don't need to
[ __ ] wear a ring and be who you're
married to myself okay what a great way
to stay single forever somebody's like
oh I married myself so what did hey look
I went to Jared promoting that about how
do you propose to them one we did you
did you T she's little Beyonce if you
love yourself you better put a ring on
it
we got it from Jared she a she
Soho bobbin brothers fell out to six
weeks salary lasts a lifetime
how do you propose to yourself you hide
it in food oh good you bite into it what
did I put in which meat so they decided
it what's this your back you standing
from the Bellagio and something you open
no package by yourself would you go to
Vegas wouldn't even make it the [ __ ] out
of here and Elvis guy breakaways might
they bury you in a cornfield
they kill you like a casino we're gonna
[ __ ] murder you bad baby here this is
aluminum baseball bats and bury you next
year brother put a Joe Pesci my astral
brother still bleeding
it is the breathing shut up Mary Joseph
yeah you stupid [ __ ] what dude yeah I
know if anybody asked me I would just I
would never talk to him again I'd be
done you're allowed to bring it date is
that like [ __ ] on the myself
marriage Wednesday whole [ __ ] it was an
open bar I think I don't know no I don't
think so
oh so then if anything out if it's open
bar I might go she talks about her
inspiration said literally heavy so she
was inspired to do this yeah what
there's this raises big and artistic
piece of [ __ ]
I don't think this in the quarter she
said I literally had the idea when I was
lying in bed recovering from flu and a
bad relation or astral projection
pulling like a case of both we asked her
here to kind of a catatonic state he's
actually projecting and they are you try
you trying to do it right now you're
trying to do it together Baggins I'm
hugging those ladies in heaven coming
interrupts them you can kill what if
your astral projection guy can't get a
boner anymore be so depressing Colin
he's impotent
yeah in the astral projection world yeah
yeah I keep on well he can only watch
his wife get ass so he's a hack after
all the other astral blur ISM know he's
an astral [ __ ] hole I'm an extra column
anumber Raji how many more minutes to
get here big Tina but you gotta take off
I got a show on 10 oh no [ __ ] where you
go I got to go in Echo Park okay yeah
he'll tell us when you got a lead out
pretty soon it told me episode 100 it
really comes around everyone under she
does know what you got to leave she said
everyone celebrates getting together
with someone becoming married but
there's no milestone society what
elebrate I'm so over this [ __ ] she said
escaping something awful a returning to
your own happiness and contentment
sorry don't patted you on the back for
your breakup lady what she broke up as
Laura's boy marrying herself if wouldn't
got a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah how how awful
was that relationship you think
oh yeah the only real I was she given
she could have afterwards was to marry
her so how jealous is that guy when he
heard that he could only be replaced by
herself years ago that's great that
actually be the perfect situation ever a
sortable [ __ ] of anybody you're like
jump out at all these ideas but we're
here right yeah I think you made the
right move
I married a woman yeah initially her
idea was to write a book in which a
woman married herself rather than pursue
that hey that's real love
she went for her she went for the good
she took it took her own the plot Oh is
she a novelist or we're seeing other
[ __ ] like I'm gonna write a [ __ ]
book about a woman who married yourself
there's a lot of [ __ ] gold to buy
there lady I'm gonna send some lady by
herself a marriage your stupid [ __ ] used
to go [ __ ] idiot do the stupid
[ __ ] idiot let's go write a [ __ ]
book great idea do it myself and I'm
going to write a book about it what I'm
an agile why am I even writing this kind
of it it's too good for a character
don't waste it don't waste it limit do
don't dream it I guarantee you this lady
has a trust bud only somebody with a
trust one has enough time to think of a
[ __ ] horseshit idea like this and to
[ __ ] it fart around and be like I'm
gonna write a [ __ ] Dom what she wrote
this is what her fridge says marry self
question mark make yogurt yesterday
that's her whole thing you guys never
see when Harry met Harry I think it was
just called Quinn Harry haha after this
is one of my favorite parts of this
after two years of writing and
researching so log of it it's a lot
easier to yes first it was never even
finished my razor oh yeah you get
married to yourself and then
everything's exactly the same as but
always they just start talking yourself
he starts adding this is not my
beautiful me she uh she read talaga me
holography so [ __ ] me I so look at me
so log of me how do you say thanks a lot
maybe this monogamous like you pronounce
it even pronouncing with that way for
years I think we must be me and really
feel me you know I'm he right here in my
arms and when you find yourself lying
helpless in my arms you know you really
love yourself
oh what a [ __ ] lies when you love
Josh you tell yourself - you really
wanted it
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo you love
yourself you tell me that it's gonna lie
what's wrong is it what the [ __ ]
remember cuz I have a tiger
tell me have you ever really about
mister without you I'm still gonna be
married to myself with or without you by
the way so salami people when I was a
divorce now you're just me who I used to
know somebody told me that my ex-wife
looks like me looks like herself because
she's married to herself but you didn't
have to cut me up yeah
the joke's on us she changed her number
she sold her note and her novel after
ooh jokes on ya do Bouchet come [ __ ]
guy get out of here yeah anyone can sell
a [ __ ] book that's of [ __ ] for
$2,500 it's weekend but we live I never
tried true I didn't have to cut me off
ah that's a great song one who wanted to
send your friends to take your records
I've seen my friends to take my records
and I changed and I don't even need my
mom now you know I'm calling I would be
embarrassing me very good now I'm just
somebody that I used to know
wait crazy song that song sounds so
crazy if you know what's okay she has if
she hooks up with someone is that an
extra marry yeah yeah she can't do that
Jimmy valiant she's not herself she said
by the end of that journey her book
riding on her journey by the way this
bus journey is using liberalism journey
I was said advocate for it as a concept
I thought I'd better do it myself
let me know it felt like an obvious step
and all my friends and family become
really into it so by the time I said why
I wanted my own wedding they were on
board to her friends and family your
enabler you neighbor are yeah you're
doing here your neighborly [ __ ]
behavior it says the nuptials are both
holy and holy unique see that wordplay
me wedding
nice day to marry me hey little me what
have I done
yeah hey little me I'm the only one good
boy that is to tweak the line it'd be
like you're Billy Idol and then just
hear this lady like me the vows
Tanner wrote were all adapted from the
biblical origins she wore a 60 pound
townn being the currency not the weight
vintage white dress and her father
malcolm a 69 year old painter and
decorator gave her a ways to herself
there he is walked her up there yeah
their dad to [ __ ] eat oh thank god the
whole family was a bunch of God they
have dopes afterwards the 50-person
strong wedding dance party danced
through the streets of Brighton and down
to the beach a you know if I saw that
walking through my service like shut the
[ __ ] up I would throw I would take a
[ __ ] and I would throw it at about my
widow face you would be if I wanted to
walk me home
the mobile to walk me home they way
[ __ ] sick I think if this is the
thing I Chubby Checker I don't know dude
I would go to Twitter I would shoot this
bridal party with the [ __ ] music yeah
they are they will walk and dance down
the streets to kendrick lamar's I love
myself which it seems like a weird pick
why not the vinyls I touch myself yeah
funnier they say it's tempting to
dismiss this as the height of generation
selfies narcissism I don't think it's
tempting I think it is 100% what you
guys order marvelous particularly the
ceremony's not legally recognized oh no
[ __ ] a letter of inquiry on the matter
to brighton and hove economic an
envelope full of his own [ __ ] he was met
with her response she was met with the
response with a picture of a guy's dick
she's mailed back to her is the response
why whatever Oneidas rapidly placed in
the middle if it is my pepperoni
doesn't fly around a rotting piece of
pepperoni on a dick your best response
to anybody going hey so could I legally
bury myself di here here's a response
new [ __ ]
they said that marriage is exclusive to
two people so that was a no but for
potater the weight of the occasion is
celebration of being single and
thoroughly enjoying it still why do you
celebrate why can't you just be cool
with it internally this lady how does
this lady I would she would have been
she's a lexapro and about 50 other
antidepressants not any more than she
married herself
everything Chris Bates that opened up
everything Oh everything closed out is
what happened initially I thought of the
wedding as a light-hearted thing held it
during the Brighton fringe so passion
bar could be a part of it oh dude I wish
I was a passerby at that time I would
love to be generous fringe keep it fresh
yeah fringe lady but I got really
nervous today before it felt like a
really important thing to be doing
especially as it was one of the first
yeah I Got News for late least important
thing you'll ever do in your [ __ ]
life she said it was one of the first
szilágyi miss marriage as many people
had seen oh woah real Trailblazer here a
lot of weight on her show here got that
you got the weight of the Salah gabion
you owe me so Haga me a few people told
me it was the best wedding they never
been to like your fav get out more and
stuff is so [ __ ] stop pandering the
atmosphere was amazing and it felt
really powerful I don't think it did man
yeah you got way too much time and money
on your hands they say uh this is on the
rise part of a bigger social trend for
women rejecting the traditional timeline
of their mothers and grandmothers woo in
forging independent paths worlds away
from the spinster stereo yeah well
there's you know there's been millions
of people throughout time we've just not
got married but they didn't [ __ ]
advertise it as like able to bury by
itself is a 37 year old woman who
married herself in New York she said I
think it's hard not to adapt whatever
society's messages are and I certainly
think that one of the messages is you
are not enough you're not with someone
else yeah you're an [ __ ] lady you
know why can you pretty pressured by
society what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
says she went a week sick she winter a
week sick lady she went her college
sweetheart in her 20s and they got
divorced yeah he's like you [ __ ] dot
they grew apart committing to herself
she said was an act of defiance
never again never again never going to
marry al and never going to marry
anybody so why yeah why do you need a
ceremony can you just go ham yeah I'm
cool I'm gonna just stay single forever
Sarah baloney I'm gonna in philosophy
salami I'll bet it's a can I guess uh by
the way can I get some swagger be all
that soap you guys are going to be
eating a little bit of crow here because
I led you down a path and you're going
to get slapped in the face with this the
notion of marrying oneself and in
popular consciousness in a 2003 episode
of six of the city okay quick Kerry much
that's before he got to celebrate
friends life life choices but never own
that's okay guys I would for you as
powerful origin is powerful you know
what I've changed my mind I believe that
this is the future ah you know what i
think i you had your a real he had a
real staunch support of not doing it but
then Sex in the City turned you like
that forget the day of my wedding to me
where I was dressed in a [ __ ] suit and
led myself wherever I am right around my
neck back and forth with my head
what's the constable of the Lake Wobegon
and I said comfortable well you fit my
opinions in my eyes yeah you uh is this
penis as thick as a wrist because I like
to finish my own [ __ ] and if I can't
I need to get the Botox shot said relax
put a slice of rhubarb pie on a 2000
actually that's what I would do if this
lady rotated I was wherever they got to
receive this I would put a picture of me
smoking a rhubarb pie and set it back to
her congratulations yeah absolutely
with love garrison keillor
and then said someone there to arrest
her
in 2010 the lead character on the
musical comedy show Glee had a solitary
wedding ceremony so it was picking up
steam oh it was ugly 2003 - laga best
yes lager that's a real song go hardly
knew her this is a real gold flogger I
hardly knew me we don't want to
consummate the relationship just yet
we're still learning about each other
going on a honeymoon of course i okay
are you leaving
I gotta go sin do it right what would a
shell organ a violin if people can go
down to the time and hey where is it
it's a Bigfoot lodge oh yeah
Bigfoot that there's a Sunday show there
okay I put dick down that's not a
Bigfoot day go check it out if you how
is that show it's great isn't it
fantastic I want to do it sometime well
I'll get you in touch with the right
people
I'm gonna go is yeah throw my named out
there tell them coming decks up day when
you had a blast
thanks for coming yeah thanks for doing
180 episode 100 every minutes do we do
we did a full episode yeah we did
but 200 we're doing 800 minutes yeah
until we go oh yeah we haven't got into
our favorite moments over the past 100
episodes the retros they write yours
down yes my to certain pages that's it
sausage castle sausage castles the guy
videotaping people [ __ ] at the park
Marty Marty you [ __ ] yeah
yadi massage not a massage this grant
was another one
what was the money was one stick out I
sing your theme song I'll sing it for
you now go ahead Danish and O'Neill
booty doo doo doo doo dee dee doo dee
doo dee doo dee dee I was Danish I was
all nil so I can tell you how they both
feel it's a free podcast so it's a
[ __ ] good deal they call me the day
is finishing O'Neill O'Neill day they
said O'Neill Danish and Oni
[Applause]
shadow Neal haha
what up B ed you do it is leaving the
building good to see a magazine good
luck in that show break a day if you've
been to the MinuteClinic
but you're still in here Danish yes are
there real people at that show so I mean
real people just relax ya know if it was
a stroke a you're not a stroke comedy
shows my favorite way to get booked stay
at home yeah is that what you're doing
on the couch you're just letting them
know you're here yep just an astral show
in Cleveland
all right life nice D Epoque soon man
yeah yeah we'll continue on thanks
thanks for to do with how many ladies
and gentlemen thanks for coming on
does that affect anything if you unplug
that mic no okay cool thanks nothing I
still got your feed coming right through
[ __ ] yeah dude be safe my friend jumping
that pool on the way out a wedding is a
marker of just a mark of lies explains
Alexandra Gill Canadian food critic who
married herself in 2006 well it's going
why they're no dudes that have married
themselves because we're got a lot of
[ __ ] going on with that in renewed
our vows on her 10th wedding anniversary
last year
imagine being invited that 10 years and
she stayed uh say trayful who blew 10
years you really missing out on a lot of
[ __ ] life just having a partner
there's nothing wrong with that yeah and
although or you just meet somebody and
you're like you know what you know what
be fun right now maybe some [ __ ] maybe
just hanging out maybe spending some
time with somebody else in breakfast
yeah talking why why limit yourself in
life to just [ __ ] like this like I'm
just going to do this and I'm sticking
to it sounds like quitting yeah it
sounds like you're just [ __ ] missing
out on a lot of [ __ ] she said our
mothers and grandmothers didn't have the
choice to remain single oh my god get
out of here
you know people [ __ ] remain single
throughout time this isn't some new high
in and on the second on who is like
singular whole life she married didn't
like it and if she didn't have a
ceremony to marry her my grandmother had
two aunts they never [ __ ] married
they'd live to be like 90 they may have
been lesbians or maybe they just weren't
into that who knows what didn't like
honey Buckhead to the max they didn't
have a ceremony to [ __ ] bother people
with herself mayor I hate when people
limit themselves in life you know why
because they're scared of getting
involved in getting their heart broken
again which cares and you'll work
through it yeah it takes time but I'll
tell you what there's nothing better
than having a [ __ ] crazy little
affair man it's what makes life worth
living
she said self marriage is an opportunity
to celebrate our personal independence
self-reliance and freedom from the
chains of convention who quickeneth
confide in you who's chaining you ya
know you're why could she she just can't
be single great congratulate but she's
like society's forcing me society is
forcing you to do nothing look at us you
think you were going to societal norm
nope not at all the [ __ ] would say we've
ruined our lives I'm working for myself
I'm so self-employed with no say come on
Lady a number of businesses and spotted
opportunities in his self marriage world
it's my yellow gold speed also doing
this it's an actor Gold Steve there's
Gil I don't know I guess Gil's a store
Gil Gil a person we had Gil drugs in my
town Gil launched marry yourself
Vancouver a wedding planning
consultation service last year well I'm
sure they have already gone under Jesus
Christ how many people could positively
doing this in Japan where one in seven
women are unmarried circa travel offers
a two-day package that provides a dress
fitting makeup and hairstyling in photo
shoot for upwards of 2,500 whatever
their currency is I'll give you a
package well you can get it yourself
married
god damn this is actually depressing to
hear it's very depressing
california-based jeweler Jeffrey Levin
he created a self marriage kit service
called I married me he's married to his
wife Bonnie but he still takes part in
this he said this is not a substitute
for a partner on the contrary it's about
being a stronger member of society and
more grounded as a person the way
to go through a ceremony to do that of
course you just try to sell rings you're
married to a woman yeah so what are you
talking about also that's the lamest
excuse I've ever heard it's not big a
better member of society it more
grounded
what could you married yourself I'm
going to argue the opposite my friend I
would argue that you are less grounded
you're actually a worse member of
society
it says not everyone likes this trend I
think we could be that boat with news of
Tanner's wedding hit the headlines a
couple years ago many on social media
were calling her a narcissist
acquaintances to having had held back a
couple of guys have become a bit
incensed she said she's continued to
date since her wedding what the [ __ ] is
that then okay that so what's the point
why are you dating you're married yeah
you took a vow I carry now man but has
no plans to marry anyone else so he just
wanna be unmarried no you know what she
want to still you wanted a party that
celebrated her and she couldn't think of
a reason why so she did this she wanted
to be the center of [ __ ] attention so
he's no face so what could I do that I
could have a whole day that's dedicated
to me and every year people have to get
together and celebrate me you're a
narcissistic [ __ ] face if you gave her a
present one you're an idiot to get it
back she's dated yeah I gotta do for if
you have you know this lady and you hang
out with her your nearest into one of
her male acquaintances told me I
couldn't have had have my cake and eat
it by marrying myself and then going on
to have other relationships do whatever
you want by the way because it's not a
real thing in a man I was having a
holiday fling with flipped out I
appreciate that you should again she's a
ring you like were you married to Oh
myself you're [ __ ] insane oh yeah I
wouldn't flip out about her being
married I would go oh you know what I
have something on to my apartment I
gotta go after I'm gonna [ __ ] real quick
and that we're going to leave she said I
was surprised by the anger it's not
harming anyone most of the guys have
been out with have been really
supportive it is it's been a good filter
to see the reaction when I tell them no
it's not as also all these guys I
guarantee it may be stayed one more date
or never called you whatever saying
enough to have sex and like yeah see
take care as if they suddenly become
wary they're not the one for me anyway I
have a feeling that no you're not
getting married so what do you mean the
one for you there's no one for you
period because you just told you you're
such an [ __ ] to hear like I'm
marrying my
so clearly nobody will give you enough
attention that you need
it's insane the good news gotta be a
dude who's done this there's got to be
dudes doing this - I didn't say very few
there's got to be some though she is one
sister from her parents marriage and
four stepsisters from her father's
second ranging in age 22 to 38 she is
thus far the only one of them to have
been a bride and it had took Marian
herself to get there you know what I
mean want to know what her line up in
that like where did she fall in that age
bracket
she's definitely craving some serious
attention here I'd say 30s but I don't
have no idea this is only a plea to get
attention
literally dude I'm engaged and I
literally don't want to have a wedding a
public wedding because I don't want the
attention I literally I don't want the
[ __ ] attention she says you can be
more lonely in a relationship that's not
functioning and just being on your own
like I don't realize that okay so yeah
but that's that's beside the point like
that makes no sense in her argument for
this
I hope seeing how empower how empowering
committing to yourself is collaborate
people and teach them that seeking
solitudes are good if you need to go
through this process to liberate
yourself you're already [ __ ] this is
deep dude you ready yeah you can waste
your life waiting for the one when you
were the one yourself
[ __ ] wasting their life waiting for the
one you forget dope it turns out you're
your own soul mate oh my god do these
people are so [ __ ] up they're so
[ __ ] up I feel I actually feel very
sorry for them it's sad it's very sad
I'm happy for you're very happy they
found themselves dude you're what kind
of [ __ ] is just sitting around be
like oh we're gonna beat the wood what I
don't know first two ligaments wedding a
little box at the bottom as an American
woman were to blame for this Linda
Barker the old Barker she got hitched to
herself in front of 75 friends and
family in 93 whoa trailblazer watch out
what was thought to be the first
ceremony of its kind about doing things
for yourself and not waiting around for
someone else to make it
watch though I don't understand why you
need to can't you just go hey you know
what I'm getting off my ass today and
I'm going to make some changes they
don't know how many of these have taken
place but people have said I me wet and
country's from Australia to the
Netherlands so I guess we're all a
little guilty can men do it do the
Church of self love doesn't discriminate
but fewer men seem to be lining up to
make it official Harun Celine I think I
guess it's a man took his vows in
Minnesota 15 years ago since then he's
felt a deep sense of peace and safety
belonging and just plain love dude if
you break up [ __ ] just you know go
out there and try again
yeah don't succeed try try again yeah
get a hobby and be quiet about it yeah
shut the [ __ ] up a lot of people do that
deal going to go to the park and read a
book or fly a kite go to the gym and
shut the [ __ ] up don't shake like a big
deal yeah and stop being such an [ __ ]
you'll meet somebody maybe it probably
I'll tell you what right now
if you said you're something like a
person who's I guarantee you her
standards were so [ __ ] out of whack
for what she expected out of another
person that there was no way that she
would ever find somebody I think that is
one of the bigger no one's good enough
for herself but herself can Plus you got
to go through a ton of failures to
realize hey nobody's [ __ ] perfect if
I get you somebody that's cool that
likes to laugh with me that's about as
good as it's going to get can you
divorce yourself not legally given solo
weddings aren't binding if you've got a
reckon second soluble differences with
yourself or have been a victim of your
own and reasonable havior yo are you
serious how to figure it out on the
upside my divorce settlements are out of
the question
wow they really dug deep on this your
settlements are other questions yeah you
go chit you stupid [ __ ] but that's like
saying as your projects you not get any
prettier ignoring the fact that you're
not [ __ ] your joint effect that
there's a specific that's real
projection or marrying yourself is so
ridiculous god what we have fallen low
and who's here to bring you stories like
this Danish and O'Neill then 100
episodes deep yeah here's to 500 more
we're entering we're going to end this
show on 600 by the way I'm saying it now
at a cap on
it's a long ways away so yeah you said
you didn't want any news or notes today
and I agree with that because it is
episode under itself day of celebration
but how can we not say that today
quit incidentally on our hundred show
what happened Kambei matumbo is 51st
birthday yeah
oh here 25 G 51 guys oh well there
though is that because he's from Africa
and there's someone I think where he's
from the records weren't great there's
speculation that he's older okay okay
that makes more sense
ah a lot like that happens with Latin
date Latin baseball players falsify a
lot yeah yeah and they turn out but him
they do suggest that he is not that he's
like 67 years old hello everyone I blow
out the candles muta oh no no I take
trip to Filipinas for my birthday if
anyone took you any presents they are
telling the truth my dog just [ __ ] you
did not sit in the house of a tub oh I
want cookies at my birthday how good of
that I wear ice cream cake from Carmel
we will always share this anniversary
date with matumbo and by the way folks
was when we started this podcast two
years ago and we did it all we line did
not strategically look into the future
and say one will episode 100 will it
fall to Kennedy with Dumbo's 51st
birthday what makes me saddened is that
the only person I found out on my own
but barb send it to me no one else so if
I didn't find it ah we wouldn't have
known listeners gotta step off now
listen Barb's gone we'll be fine Barb's
leave it will be fine well we're gonna
have to do from now on is everybody
brings in two articles as they want to
talk about I can collect it
yeah what uh what do you want to go to
one of our last toys we have a goat
attacking a boy we have a rapper getting
a little too crazy on stage it really
turns on it's a good one they do that
couple died having sex oh the one where
they go and they sing at a car yeah that
would that would sad and that man
nothing worse than when that man [ __ ]
goes wrong a policeman dressed up
that man makes a big arrest as Batman
let's go with the rapper rap very good
you're not going to regret that choice
it was from George thanks George see we
have where we go we have support out
there barb
yeah barb I know you're still listening
a bar of your birth you ever want to
come back Barbie bird a bridge Wow have
you burned a big bridge barb what O'Neil
saying is not true
devil bees barb someone sent me an
article from awesome Australian
publication now which was false so now
I'm scared no I'm gonna check this is
from Australia hold on one second talk
amongst yourself ok marry yourself over
there yeah I'm going to talk Hey Dude
where daddy's still here hey what's
going on here what's going on pretty
good straight out over here doing
nothing it was good having two we're
back on the show and very good it's been
a long time mainly my fault or all my
fault
six months or so I think oh this video
of this so this is real okay so here we
go should we watch the video this sites
not working hold on come on man the
rappers YG's one of these uh New Age
rappers like he sings he by the way
there's a real rapper he's a rapper I
think he's one of these like you might
be a trap rapper I'm not sure though
with the folks at rap rap rap music like
the Von Trapps from on her to track down
the music the Millennials are into it I
came out and I don't just listen to that
indie [ __ ]
I want the quotes or their quotes I need
quotes Huffington Post did not cover
this well god damn it
barb wait we need you part harp suit up
barb get you one piece on melon we need
you condition almond you could donate my
body to science fiction hello I know is
I got a lot of balls you know my doctor
doctor vide boom bets um right now do
you know we're losing what a retention
why because I'm blowing it with this
story now cuz barb failed us I blame
everything on barb now Barbara why is
barb forsaken I'm still gonna listen to
the show or she's done with that - you
know she's gonna listen
this is from the Sydney Morning Herald
one of my famous barb listen to all the
boner cities and all the Danish toenails
she has Jesus so video is a merge of
touring us rapper yg demanding female
fans take their tops off okay that's not
going to go well turns out it was an
all-ages concert oh she's in Brisbane
what a [ __ ] idiot yeah what the [ __ ]
turns out they weren't all legal
bad move I want to buy a vowel idea a yg
you really [ __ ] up I loved her an
all-ages show there were probably kids
there what a [ __ ] dope Wow he singled
out women in the audience telling those
on people pay you the twelve-year-old
ticket to up off telling those on
people's shoulders to flash their chest
I'm sure you didn't say chest what if
the hunger holds under dad's shoulders
it's my daughter you pieces a broccoli
backpedals after learning that the
venue's upper-tier we're underage did
somebody probably I might let up a day
around the rager yes I sent him a note
on stage oh [ __ ]
he does say oh [ __ ] y'all are underage I
can't [ __ ] with y'all okay he tells the
younger concert goers after a bouncer on
stage appears to inform of the gigs 13
plus update oh my god
there was 13 year old allowed in here he
that tells the kids to promise they'll
go to school on Monday hey by the way
kids I just really think your tops off
put it back on stay in school
come on guys let's do or what all right
you know what maybe the best
backpedalling let's see let me see okay
we're show titty together all might
there's a situation in this you get a
guilty sob rapper
I'll be the security guy come on
everybody come on get up push put your
hands in the air come on take your tops
off you're on somebody's shoulder let me
see they're bidding
a UH a yg yeah man talk to you for a
second yeah oh my Grob yes you are
this is some 13 year old girl to the
crowd tonight that's Australian age
right man here between no same is the
America needs to say Thursday man
they're gonna have a bat missing woman
you know I would just tell them to stay
in school maybe she could kill with that
right oh [ __ ] oh god I'm [ __ ] up man I
can't [ __ ] with y'all you're 13 I'll
come back in five years I'll tear that
as a box can school everybody
it tells her go to school on Monday
Monday guys come on don't be late look
at them tardies it should camera at all
the video also shows the rapper
insulting women in the audience oh my
god he said baby you look like you've
got mosquito bites put your ass down he
tells Wow
I didn't like he didn't look you asked
to see the titties and then you
criticized them you didn't like even
look if you asked to see the kid
anything like that set and you you're
responsible for like them all what yes
you have to if because they're doing you
a favor
he didn't know be an [ __ ] you didn't
like them what you would skeeto bites by
the way small titties are great small
T's are great big ol titties are great
is that your uh that's piyah under slow
that's my official medical analysis that
was his last show I believe there was a
effort I believe it was no in Australia
but I believe it said there was a cops
involved after that would I mean what do
you get for that he didn't know but they
it is that it is inappropriate though so
is it against the law there they should
show me your titties let's see this is
Huffington Post hope oh tujhe tough but
that's it sir he was told by the the
dude said stay in school his album lies
27s most famous for his album still
brazii
oh yeah it's one of his best the record
features a pre-election protester act
entitled fdt [ __ ] Donald Trump
it could be literal all it says is
rapper yg cops backlash after asking
woman and then it says nothing about
that so huh
okay
you have it I guess somebody looked into
it I don't know if that's a crime I'm
assuming they like what's probably wrong
with you it's just not good PR I would
say makes me want to buy his album make
sure we go to his next concert video no
seems like the videos I think it's PR
taken that down I would uh from
Compton's Oh Izzy yeah I would love to
go to a show and have them critique my
titties I would love it yeah I was
pretty made Australia you may want to
ban YG's previous time in the country
with fellow la rapper ty dolla sign the
tight dollars than high tide dollar swim
the son of the Esav sinus is a dollar
side dollar side yeah that's a great
[ __ ] they were there January 2015 I
did a gig at the N word Theatre in which
a 15 year old girl was incident decently
insulted I don't think by them but Wow
so although he really and you letting
your kid Hannity's may not want it you
might want to skip these guys if you
have an underage girl in your home
yeah but they do have a good message of
staying in school
yeah and Thai dollar signs a great
[ __ ] name yeah you got that going for
you you do which is nice feel like we
need at least one animal story for
episode of all right then let's wrap
this you want Tracey's monkey rodeo we
can get seems like it would take a lot
of time though monkey oh you mean
they're banning the monkey roadie okay
you want to go a go this goat attacks
pretty good I go to tech is from Devon
you just friend of the show yeah active
is from Gawker it's still up you know I
just watched by the way since we're
talking about Gawker here watch the new
Netflix documentary about the Hulk Hogan
Gawker case it's going to make you look
at things a little differently my friend
really yeah it's a for him or against
him no it's just because you know that
billionaire was behind it all right yeah
the guy says Hogan yeah so then it just
goes on about basically billionaires
controlling the media and what comes out
of it it it is true that the billionaire
was Gary is it true the billionaire was
pissed that he took his parade said his
prayers and took his vitamins and the
happened no but it's great because
there's uh there's a video of Hogan
talking about having he said because you
know he says there's Terry and there's
Hulk Hogan yeah it's two different guy
nice and magic John and they heard it
well you said Hulk Hogan attended fetus
he's like Hulk Hogan that does have a
tented fetus but Terry's penis is that
that big guys Terry I Terry right now do
not have a tenant's penis this is back
and forth this is on the stand yeah the
other say this is testimony so but if
you [ __ ] old Cogan you're getting a
ten-inch er yeah how's that possible he
said it just gets it could he prove it
medically could be put on the yellow and
red bandana you saying that there's two
different people one's a superhero yeah
one is attending to dick what Terry does
not so as anyone ever said his isn't
anywhere near 10 inches is Terry the
only one doing the [ __ ] or Hulk ever
take oh I think Terry only [ __ ]
I don't think whole Hulk doesn't [ __ ]
yes there's no way to prove whether I
heard Hulk has a full head of hair
he actually talks about a full head of
hair there the health headline it is he
said what like he talked about the
origins of Hulk and he's like it was
about powerful head of hair what he said
Hulk doesn't have a leathery skin Hulk
isn't at eighteen back surgery isn't
lost height from by the way they say
hooks six foot seven he looks about 510
I saw him in LA once he's not much
taller than me I'm six-three yeah I
think he was maybe not even probably six
to now but he's had like a ton of the
injury I don't think he was ever even
smear six seven to begin with but it's
all it was just all about and then you
know how they were publicizing that that
the guy who wrote the article for Gawker
yeah I made a joke well he said we
wouldn't publish a sex tape of a child
and they're like up to what age and he
goes for but in print better that was
very damning but if you watch the video
it was basically he was just giving some
testimony on tape and he was laughing
wasn't he doing a line from Rodney
Dangerfield back to school for uh and
you could see the guy smoked he's like I
was just like [ __ ] with the guy
because I was suing me and print that's
bad yeah real life you're making a
stupid joke like [ __ ] you it's a dumb
question they really dug into it and
then it turns out like there's all these
billionaires that are literally just
trying to [ __ ] keep what the
billionaire was pissed at Gawker so he
funded Hogan yeah because the Gawker
went after the billionaire one point god
what he's a billionaire claims he was
pissed about Gawker outing his gay but
Gawker actually just wrote a article
about being gay in Silicon Valley and
like how is it acceptable this is that
it wasn't anything damning but what they
were doing was going after a lot of
different things that happened in
Silicon Valley and I think that's what
the guy was really pissed about because
now the guy is being groomed by Trump
you might be run for president he also
wants to build Islands and international
waters that are away from all government
overseeing you have a lot of money [ __ ]
you can do is scare guys also autistic
and that's the guy you member the first
season of Silicon Valley yes the guy
that died yeah they based that guy off
this guy better be careful
they say the unbelievably smart and he's
incredibly autistic so back to Gawker
Utah I guess is like some sort of goat
revolution going on first there was the
mysterious goat man wandering around the
Utah wilderness it was him serious about
was just a go guy got it down to go
there's a link I don't feel like closing
on it now there's a goat named Voldemort
Harry Potter shout out who attacked its
a pet goat who attacked a paper boy by
the way I've been attacked by a goat
let's see if I can relate to this story
goats are aggressive but it sounds
humiliating for this paper boy okay he
14 his name is Jackson where's 14 yeah
it's old foreplay kind of old to be
attacked by goats and to be a paperboy
yeah his name's Jackson spelled with an
ax Jack so maybe the paper boy could be
spelled it with a bat Jack's on Jack's
off Jack's on Gessle was minding his own
business delivering oil he wasn't well I
guess he was literally minding his own
business with paper boy business yeah
delivering papers on his early morning
paper out went out of pre-dawn darkness
an animal approached Castle thought it
was a dog
then it made a weird noise kind of like
grunting noise you said the shadowy
figures started coming at him I'm like
what the heck is that the goat who
belongs to nearby family is named for
some reason Voldemort I would say it's a
Harry Potter reason not just
reasoned head-butted Gessle knocking him
from his bike
whoa he then tried to escape but the
goat reared back on its hind legs and
tackle them she still come to the ground
grounded but yeah it just freaked me out
when it stood up on the tiny legs it
just wrapped its front legs around me
and it pulled me off ha ha ha ha guy one
of his paper guess so who was forced to
climb a nearby tree where he stayed for
over an hour
Voldemort continue to wreak havoc
chasing after anyone who walked past
eventually the goat ran after two young
girls at which point Gessle says he
jumped from the tree and chase that go
for two blocks real hero
come on so this guy was scared of the
goat that he took he goes from the
hunted to the hunter oh yeah I don't buy
it coming out he's trying to get some of
that young ass we don't know how old the
girls were yg don't touch him that are
under 18 I'm saying this point had been
over 90 minutes since Gessle was due
home so his parents called the copy this
whole thing took 90 minutes yeah they
treat him for an hour and then he chased
him down the street which took him in he
was ninety minutes late so he was in the
tree for an ALICE people are waiting for
their papers - his parents called the
coppers amish they're Brandon Muse who
called the council your kid's 90 minutes
late who called the cops on a paper I
was like well I don't know you figure to
wait 24 hours I don't know
obviously officer Brandon mirror was
looking for themselves you know I don't
know if he I guess he was out of the
office he was looking for my window
doesn't [ __ ] do goat searches he was
looking for the kid when he got a call
about a boy and a ghost sounds not like
a boy but can we go to take over here he
he arrived on the scene and was bad for
this kid is that Voldemort was friendly
and welcoming no way he said it jumped
on me a few times but he wasn't that
hard to catch do you think that this kid
was up to something no good and they
made up the goat story I don't know I
just think this kid is a bit like me and
a successful being scared of that sort
of goat didn't have horns right no I
don't think so because me and my buddy
there was a goat that lived in a field
behind his house and he had horns and it
would chase the [ __ ] out of you now
everyone at schools given Gessle a hard
time everybody there all hey go boy I'm
like hey guys
people job people are just like why are
you scared to go so I'm like that was a
freaky goat I think it's like possessed
or something okay
yeah well you might be just a nerd sorry
as for old Amorites back at home I feel
horrible that the whole thing happened
said his owner right that would be good
if it was a goat still doesn't change
they do have horns
you grab the horns of a goat and easily
control it here's the pic no I don't see
any just looks like a [ __ ] weird a
big eyed goat
yeah dude this guy his [ __ ] kid he
got a handle you know what you gotta
read by it he might deserve to get
bullied for a little while Kim some
backbone I like how he's like he's like
answers dude hey guys hey guys the guy
got goaded yeah he got as good kind of
go girl gotta go you think he's going to
carry goat mace now probably I hope so
yes but it sounds like he's coddled
because the parents called the cops
immediately yeah cuz he was out a half
late dude come on our a half identity
like three days late before they called
the cops I mean we grew up in a
different era where that also my dad
probably would not call the cops would
expect us [ __ ] come if they probably
do not him let's get because I try to
get to me go through him you better not
a talk let's flee the country
I also if I open a tree for an hour
because a goat is down there I'm gonna
figure out a [ __ ] way to get away
from this goat I'd spend probably 30
minutes in the tree and then jump down
to see what it's for the one of the pigs
goat knocked me on my bike I would kick
this [ __ ] goats ass I check the goat
I think of an animal attacks you should
legally be able to fight back even you
can you can kill it for self-defense if
it's I mean you better hope that the
nobody has reports like this cop doesn't
just walking up to him and like being
friendly he could have killed that go
could have broken its neck and it would
have been legal or just a boot to the
gut or you stand your ground and push
back there's a stand-your-ground law in
Utah for go charges you yeah you can
stand your ground cuz oh he's not a bike
also the reason that it chased him is
because he ran that's what that's what
[ __ ] animals do when you
run they chase you if you run from a cow
they'll probably chase you by the way
new article black bears are now
attacking people I saw it
tack to different people now the old a
kid within a running
16 euro they set out black where a taxi
you don't run they'll chase you no
Grizzlies you black birds are supposed
to scare away Grizzlies slowly walk away
they said worse comes the worst and of a
black bear attacks you and you're in the
mist with it or let you know you're in
the throes of yeah violence you got to
punch the nose or punch the face like
that's worst case in their could look
like you've tried bear spray tried
everything you know what though I one
time I was really scared was I when it
was winter after we picked the corn from
our fields yeah we would let the cows go
in and eat whatever was left over he
stalks and leftover corn must have been
a real good day for them yeah so that
you would have him out there but they'd
be out of the field so then we would
walk through the field to go hunting but
you would walk through a pack of a
hundred cows and then they would start
following you and sometimes the bull was
there and the bull would get crazy and
it'll charge you both on parade and it
was scary I was a little kid so you have
a bull that's literally bouncing around
jumping around and then we would start
running and there all the [ __ ] cows
would start chasing I couldn't even go
like within a block of your home it
would have I was a young man now I could
but what we did realize is the cows all
thought we had food and so they were
running towards us because they thought
we would feed them you should have
whipped them with the stock but it was
like a stampede chasing you down so it
was like Lion King and there was nowhere
to go
Mufasa gets trampled it was scary
spoiler alert that is the only time
they've really been like truly terrified
animals in factory you know we had to go
in the creek though the only time I was
scared of animals was every time [ __ ] I
hate working with animals I love it I
was living in raw sewage and I loved it
episode 100 I can't wear your
reflections back on that can't believe
it I mean we've done the show of all
from a show that was dual audio at the
beginning by accident yeah
thanks to re Manas was a good person
last name shoutout
Ari Shaffir would be proud of it uh
because you give the height weight at
Social Security number they'll be great
I was episode one watch Ari Shaffir
special June 16th but watch it to the
very eyes of July yeah watch it for the
very head when do you see read the
special things we recorded our episode
with Ari Shaffir skeptic tank we did it
by a campfire or a fire how do you think
that one's make it what good I don't
know anymore now my mic stinks like so I
had to get a new mic it's not in my hand
it's important for you [ __ ] perfect
so much did he smell the asses in front
these have been in two fires and they
haven't been washed you recipe smell the
crotch or the ass yeah I'll just between
the two yeah the show has evolved a lot
it was like I don't do I don't know if
we were doing mainly the stories we kind
of found it we were we started yeah I
think we did involved a lot early on I
think we were just trying to figure out
what a two-man podcast would be we came
from the boner City world yeah but uh
now I think we've established what the
show is a informational it's a it's a
cultural critique show its [ __ ] on
society it's a societal it's a mirror
societal judgment joke it's a mirror for
society it's a black mayor it's very
black I yeah I mean we did 89 episodes
of one and we've done 100 here plus
we've done about 50 on the side of about
250 podcasts in what will our let what
will our podcasting legacy be uh strong
the quite strong I don't know I mean we
wish it we've been heard by a lot of
people a thank you guys for listening
and for those you've been with us it's
boner City we appreciate it those who
are newer to the game we promise you
five hundred more episodes but no
guarantees after that we've got a lot of
guests from Andrew Dice Clay wheels Gary
Keeler GSP Diaz brothers
we've had actual guests in studio John
little Eleanor Kerrigan Jerry Rocha
entered the wit Steve Rannazzisi he run
is easy very reluctant every time who
else have we had uh Bush man Bush man
how could I forget boy yeah Boosh
Jerry Rocha I said Jerry Jon little I
said not it I think that's it I'll even
somebody off but now we haven't had that
many guests he really had a lot of
reoccurring stories that stick out to me
Eric Heights has to be one occurred over
a long what I feel like
Eric Heights kind of was when we started
solidifying our podcasting voice the the
man who imitates rocky was a good one
okay left of the only negative review
that we have allegedly Sal's Uno is
recent I mean obviously the horse or
anything is this course [ __ ] put us
on the milk if Eric Heights is where we
hit our stride horse cookies when we
beat it was called the peak nests
it's a horse joke for you the guy
introduces a [ __ ] wife or girlfriend of
the show recently Easter off of the
horse episode Yap I not said well you
know what don't know trial by fire
that's either have she like deepest
darkest parts and if she likes that
she'll like the rest you'll love it so
identical other day you know what it is
throwing somebody in to that is like
blasting off on the shrooms yeah it's
it's hard you go to be waves you go
sixty right away goddamn you got to
buckle down I'm trying to think other
great stories of that obviously a lot of
Batman guys dressed up as Batman a lot
of animal attack of stories just a lot
of good around doctor love who'd Ron
Horton I just saw tweeted Joe Rogan
about Rogan loved it we've been covering
it all along everybody started tweeting
Rogan
we're not johnny-come-lately we should
start weeping people often include us on
tweets to Rogen clinically have similar
interests when it comes to animals
attack and all the other stuff anime if
you know what he's just gotten into he
pick on the Vibrams the real life I wish
I would have thought he would have been
an early know he's just started to stop
there
we just started wrong he said like you
need realized his cardio was bad and he
like always stayed away from running so
he's currently here and no I say I'm
just like a weight guy never did cardio
Wow
interest until he was like I realized I
needed to address it or he wanted to
well I try to go what else what other
legs I mean obviously the bush episodes
are standalone
just excellence I don't know I don't
know I think there's been some weak
episodes but there's been a lot of
strong ones way more strong and weak
yeah that's for damn sure
just try to get the show build the show
that things are after 100 big things are
happening we've got a few big
announcements I want to right here now
but I'll do it yeah soon one things all
I think in the next couple episodes
there's going to be some big announced
some interesting things come in are
learning development it's not going to
change what's happening here and now
it's not going to change anyone's life
if they want as they listen the show but
there's going to be new additions
there's going to be new homes for places
it's going to be fun
yeah we'll see what happens yeah so stay
tuned for that and yeah like we said
thank you to you guys for listening
maybe 100 we built it up to be out I
mean we really have three mics we were
little or at the end of the day it's
just that you know our hands were tied
it's just another show you know I mean
we're going to put on a [ __ ]
revolution but the revolution will not
be televised at the end of the day it's
just another show but uh thank you for
making our show for those of you that do
your first stop
yeah on Mondays and don't fast forward
keep us up there on those laughable is
our attention it's all about everything
we're not here for numbers rear for
pretend you know I'm getting tweets I
just got one earlier from we're selling
this [ __ ] creative cursing book you
know people should start selling her
know dog bite just got his it is you
know we all that the all the juice
message this all comes from Alicia my
friend it all does come from Alicia but
we're selling them I know
she she bought you she bought one for
herself oh by the way how can we leave
out the Segal contactually area yeah
to cornerstone to the show Cigala the
Shanghai episode is one of the best out
there I'm gonna I'm gonna flip to all
wipe ah ball glob uh put a piss Club
that's gonna help me here's what glob
you're sticking with glob you need a new
Oh about a [ __ ] plug that's that might
be a good that's a good one that's a
plug that you go in a lot of different
outlets a [ __ ] plug remember the Bed
Bath & Beyond story where two homeless
gay guys [ __ ] on one of their heads
yeah we sold in the discount bin yeah
but everyone is still I'm not oddly I'm
getting memories remember the story that
started the air raid alarm of the lady
who felt like she belong in the world
war two era where she's having trouble
dating yeah yeah she's nobody
she was eating like their shoes in
[ __ ] war ration it was food it was
all of the era yeah man yeah that's real
cool when the sirens Kings eyes playing
the siren then you got so angry that is
overfunded first then they weren't
funded abort we're going to end it with
anybody see Richard we can't we're
scared to play a sound bite stuff you
notice yeah we were following the
guidelines of a [ __ ] lunatic it was
like later told me bad bragging food
whatever yeah apparently yeah you know
everyone in the podcasting world very
liberal with playing sound bites but if
some are not some are even some early
guys I was talking to a friend I won't
say who it was he said that he was told
by a podcaster early on never do that
[ __ ] yeah so we've made the mistake a
few times but hopefully we get through
unscathed we'll see it's hard to say
going forward I got a plan to uh to do
reduce and sound
we'll say reduce you get the bush man on
in the next hundred will get John little
on soon
Eleanor Kerrigan could be back maybe
some people are suggesting O'Neill's
comedy Sun sank Chao never never
fifty fifty people have to suggest he's
a listener forty nine you know listener
of the show I know I'm addressing him
directly he traveled of the board it
just ever be on this [ __ ] show
news flash ah quick why update and then
we'll get out of here
I brought my lady friend Courtney to the
Y today she said to me you know I've
heard you talk a lot about your swimming
prowess I think she wanted to know if
she was with a liar yeah what'd she say
so I brought her and I said her mind was
so blown said to the guide to desk first
of all there's no parking there today
which was very annoying on the street
Sunday men but then the street and the
lot was full Sunday people of the day
off again go to the why usually it's
fine
on a Sunday I've been on Sundays who
knows maybe it was the holiday I told
the guy to - she was visiting me from
out of town
excited another policy actually mind if
she comes yeah fine too soon
something tells me you could have just
walked in and he would have said I
should have given her some bags and like
raggedy clothes and like just say you're
homeless and I'll let you go shower
doing you could just watch my pie not
sort of plated worldly by the rules
yeah no problem no one else there done
so I go in to swim she sat on the bench
there benchwarmer yeah she told me I was
like what you do there usually are on
the way into the studio yeah I go what
would you do if she goes I sent him the
pension watch she was on her phone a lot
I could see the point
oh yeah right like it was weird I go
yeah that is weird it's like why did why
didn't you sue she didn't want to work
she wanted to witness it okay
she wanted to check it out she asked
another shirt in your workout so you
don't have to go yeah but I wanted to my
full work she's made her sit there a
baker
she walked so apparently there was all
sorts of drama while I was in the pool
that I had no idea about this could be
happening to me every time so I could
see you know it will go ahead but this
is like there's a reoccurring
theme here and it might be you it could
be me me I'm go ahead
there was a muscle-bound man in his Lane
next to me who I saw as I was getting
ready to swim and real a real meet
pistol he had his shaved head he looked
a little bit like you know MMA Wanderlei
Silva no tattoos a very Jack big guy
exoti builder style guy wearing a black
speedo yeah and so I guess Courtney said
zexal those yeah Zack walked in astral
farting Courtney said at one point I
think he was standing by the wall and I
splashed him with my stroke was he fully
Cavia to our bodysuit no but I splashed
him and I guess it got in his eyes or
his face and he I guess he was became
enraged to the point where she said he
was staring me down in the water and
what would you splash him with a turn
kick I thought I thought she said no
just with my arms like a stroke gone
awry did you maybe a sloppy swimmer so
he got so enraged that he got out went
to the hot tub to talk to his other
friend where they talk [ __ ] about me for
like ten minutes
she said what were they saying she
didn't tell me
but then he faced that needs to be like
a wife stenographer he does his typing
with the sound for recording yeah he
hurt because the way the jacuzzi is
configured if you're sitting in it
normally your back is to the pool yeah I
mean I guess so he was on like the outer
sides if you could fit on the other side
and face the pool but his back she said
he turned around and was just staring me
down the whole time shaking his head
muttering man when he gets back in the
pool and I could see this he timed it so
I we had we were left at the same time
in the wall and he was sprinting but he
didn't have his head in the water and in
slow mode all but was going all out and
like we were like neck I'm swimming like
a piece of 114 laughs I'm not sprinting
and he like barely beat me and so then
she said he stopped at the wall was
gasping and then did an arm slap on the
water like yeah [ __ ] yeah man take that
and you were oblivious to all of this
yeah I'd no clue he was right
next no we're race isn't the first time
that you've been in trouble for
splashing it is not the first delegate
this is like the fourth it's uh it's up
there do you see all the people have in
common is they don't wear goggles wear
goggles no probably are in the water
dude how hard are you splashing that
he's like cannonball style I know it's
just like some water
shrapnel I had a guy though some fat guy
was buck naked in the showers and he
started talking to me I couldn't hear
him so I'd to go closer which may have
been a yell boy he's a kid talking about
dick you all right but he he started
saying I haven't written down that
you're splashing too much now he said
anything this is plastic a little he
said are you naked at this point no I
was in my um and he's naked yeah he said
have you ever heard of total immersion
swimming and then I couldn't hear that
so I said what in that and he repeated
it he started doing demonstrations guys
fully naked facing me yeah big Wang no
he described my stroke as scrappy I go
for power I don't know if I know that's
why dude I stopped being coached at 12
no I know but that's why your power and
your splash and everybody you may not be
an indoor swimmer did he said I said one
of my arms slaps a little bit yeah
that's like that creator he said I was a
good a good swimmer he did make sure to
say that but I looked up this Total
Immersion to see if we could teach me
anymore help me it was like this [ __ ]
very zen gliding slow rowboat style like
a divot maybe then it's you you work on
form only and I don't know dude you I
mean this is it's just like the fourth
incident yeah you almost got beat up for
it maybe I'll quit I saw the guy no you
say how to work your scrappy swimmer I'm
gonna scratch you what you learned how
to swim on the streets I swim with ones
you literally if you're our swimmer on
power but these are indoor no finesse
this is your like a river swimmer I'm a
power I'm swimming for power man the
splashes they were goggle get you killed
you're in a pool can get you [ __ ]
again it could be my undoing I don't
think it's the dude but you put it on
these people but
they know God I know but here's what
you're going for people I guess what man
we're all Russian oh but that oh and one
was a jack maybe it's time age I'll go 3
but what you hit for your fault it's
your problem I have to ask Courtney if I
seem that aligned if it did seem
aggressive yeah it was aggressive
splashing she said that the female
locker room at some of the similar
antics to the male locker rooms right
now I see if I get a response yet she
said there's a lady doing Riverdance the
female locker room the ladies literally
river dancing was my swimming overly
aggressive yeah let's see what happens
maybe that'll be the ultimate in swim
prevention maybe she said yeah it was it
was so aggressive
you know both but I was left you know
who she saw former grocery food delivery
customer romulus the infamous ramu she
said he talked to the lifeguards upon
coming in which I've seen in their trap
there and I've seen them chuckling
though you can't you can't give a guy
like that any any sign of enjoyment now
he'll stay there
you know what when he coughed into my
mouth i I didn't give any shout of
enjoyable yeah and he took the hint she
I he felt the need to talk to her I know
which is I'll tell you what I'm your
first encounter with Romulus she got
gold though so Romulus saw her hug this
muscular man who hated me this shows the
company keeps he's friends with Romulus
they hugged Romney I said I haven't seen
you in a while minutes there was no
shirt yeah and he was huge I love huge
bathing citizens that you know is huge
he doesn't his arms don't come out of
the pool so you're like it's like dog
you go crazy gonna drown so this guy
hugged Romulus and apparently said I
think Romney who said you have a good
heart to the man the man left out of
earshot he turns the Kourtney and said I
got myself a freak when he's a freak
touch or a free grab or something oh
yeah I think grab because you got to get
it when you can put a pervert
if I've been hugging this guy for years
and I thought they were innocent do you
think he moved where he lived to be
directly krusty from the why probably
window faces right there he's walking
distance he still probably drives over
ami to more points a woman swimming with
glasses on and putting her head in the
water and some other were not like a
cloud you can yeah you could do that
their vision that bad I mean I wouldn't
do it i don't i go if i go the ocean i
don't wear glasses bizarre then the
other day saw a homeless woman at the
front doors she was inside as I'm
walking in she yells [ __ ] water
to a guy who works there I'm almost
positive his name's not Arthur he says
miss please come outside he opens both
doors and let you know like you would to
like an animal please go out that way
like you're trying to get a fly out of
your car she said I will she yells to
that I will not give you a [ __ ] loud
it would be like but folks I didn't ask
for a [ __ ] what's weird is the front
doors like there's a desk and then right
behind the desk is like like the
Nautilus weights like not free weights
and like various like vice bikes and
[ __ ] like station like so everyone turns
and it's like like whoa why won't you
give him a blow job tonight so there are
kids in there
summertime so there's like kids programs
it was crazy
he goes you can't talk like that in here
do you know what you're doing in my mind
I'm like no she doesn't know what she's
doing she's clearly his mental problem
why the [ __ ] she wandered in dude ah no
that she's like one of the people they
like one of the people as they let in
I'm sure Oh [ __ ] rip like you're
becoming look if you're not gonna give
me a [ __ ] you got to get out of here
I remember that with what if he really
did ask her for a [ __ ] maybe did I
wrote an email to the director and again
co-executive director of the why no
answer addressing that addressing how
there's a gaping hole in the wall that I
tweeted out where the shower handle
should be and it just left there [ __ ]
just a huge hole low did you address it
to the director and like co whatever the
position under that answer sure they're
right up top
yeah they're not on top of it like we're
just trying to get women out of here
that are screaming will not give you a
[ __ ] you see I have time to worry
about the shower well it was in that I
mentioned that I'm like that's the sort
of riffraff I see in here maybe it's
time I take my talents to someone we get
back to who Courtney no but I know
something just came in there we go some
just came in ha ha what ex question mark
exclamation point no period whoa
take that you know I like that I'm going
to watch you you're welcome
I would have come block yeah I'd love to
hear your report you'd be horrified if
you're gonna bring like a scientific
equipment
there's staff I'm not sitting anywhere
I'm gonna wear the shoe covers well
you're visiting an open house you know
like I'm gonna flick I'm operating in
the o.r like you're murdering some looks
like an operating room you can you're
welcome anytime you'd like or I'll come
on I'll go to that pool in Eagle Rock oh
no [ __ ] that place
ah my place did you dirty no I'm just
saying too far we don't need a lie you
need to see it well I want to see this
stroke because I got to know maybe
they're too aggressive dude I think I'm
not making friends at the why I'm not
there to make friends I'm there to
dominate and if I see that your
competitions Romulan if I see this bald
guy I'm whipping him in a race and I
will whip them and I'll fly me why do
you have the proof here he whipped him
nobody beat me today oh but he was
trying super hard to make me laugh I was
running I was swimming over my father
you it does Bobby does bother you no are
we shall i everybody is really stuck in
your craw
uh-oh I'm dominating him he'll be
dominating while you issue the challenge
publicly I'll say hey ball ball see what
you got [ __ ] hey you took me out
when I wasn't looking ever you come at
me it up I gotta see the splashing I'm
worried you're worried for me worried
about the splashes whatever people are
having meetings I think quarters like I
can throw this place but I think you
could you'd be heartbroken
like what all the riffraff
I don't know if Cordy knows how what
aggressive swimming yes you might just
be trying to be nice not an expert
telling she swims whoa good thing I'm an
expert you are an expert I was the judge
of the violet swimming cover the last
Olympics you were her swimming yeah
really yeah it's why I was gone for a
while I didn't even know that judge via
Skype that's been post-show tock ladies
and gentlemen episode 100 post show talk
let's get up and those articles in or if
you want any suggestions or anything and
that doesn't fail to give to people next
episode this episode was just for and
for those of you who said could you wish
me a happy birthday or anything I'll get
to those next episode sorry for late but
uh this is all about us we're marrying
ourselves that was episode 100 in the
books by the way BJ Penn Lassa Dennis I
wrote oh my god oh wait who won Johnny
Hendrix
who can't make weight at any division
are you kidding I mean how do you go up
to 85 and miss [ __ ] weight if you
don't want to do it don't do it you know
I just think not for you and you get the
compulsion to miss weight
he's not so tiny I think he got whipped
I bet you got whipped clay guida one
yeah but I bet you he got whipped by
that because he was fighting uh what's
his name he's fighting to do two way
bigger do these cards right in boats
dude it's gotten to a point where I know
no one on these cards I know I was
almost no one sad part as I've lost
interest I think I'm in this I was
actually more about Bellator 180 dude I
was totally I was did you know Saanen
said he claimed he choked out t don't
underweight you were choked out yeah
what's he saying it's just like he's one
of his wrestling pawns I got choked out
Tito Ortiz in a minute yeah in the crowd
he claimed what Tito was getting home
hit and like Tito was doing some antics
on the side during the fight people who
love it at El really he's [ __ ] gone
and now wants to fight phaidor and it's
like we just lost though so how is that
a good fight yeah I think I go by the
way
Mitrione was standing next to fate or
patron with [ __ ] so much bigger than
fate or
Tim Boetsch TKO head kick and punch yeah
and what rounds surround - yeah good
there we go
all right dude Johny Hendricks cannot
fight at 85 talking to you Jane is gonna
cut them yeah for sure because it can't
make weight in a division make weight at
205 you'd miss weight crazy I'm a new a
new mic guy this thing stinks like smoke
inserting my throat I glad dude your
ears suck it crazy I'm not crazy
dude it's a climatic Woody or not
alright
play the song let's get out it Barbara
just sent me this this is a live show
200 it's what I don't want it you wanted
to know if you celebrate this here's the
caption we'll look I know what it barb
my feelings are hurt
so as naked hikers ignore cop tickets
they hit threaten to hit the trails in
the buff you for that are where this I
will go watch people walk he says i
Griffith Park is that it's a no that'd
be great
I tell you where it is New York Post and
by the way barb sent me this [ __ ]
road rage fight incident did you see
this video which will it's in Reseda no
well it's tremendous on these chicks are
[ __ ] whoa you may want to check this
out I know I want to find out where it
is yeah I want to go there who are those
people or go I want to join well now
you're not so hurt I want to join that
big club Colorado there's there was a
stasis we're celebrating nude hiking day
you know they have nude skiing day to
really when it gets warm like around
April I hiked naked day it's not they
said it's not recognized by a by the law
yeah so these ladies were shut down I'll
watch the street fight later alright
thank you guys thanks for listening
let's play the theme song to get out of
here best theme song in the business
best fans in the business we were told
by another podcaster recently that we
have most rabid fans and we think that
we do yes unlike that woman with that
raccoon and last episode we're not going
to put you in a puddle and drown yeah
we're here for you
we're not against you
[Music]
danish own you know me grant me harm a
little steel Danish and O'Neal
visible MinuteClinic just like you take
care kitties jammy beef chow mein
oh I also have find today said hobo hobo
beef soup
ha ha ha did you stop by the restaurant
all it said was it had some writing it
did Korean in addition home of beef and
then you stop the Paladins this is the
beef soups what's in the toilet FK yeah
so quick kind of [ __ ] pro oh is that
oh wait it's just what was the beef soup
I gotta get in there
this is a beef soup place no bowls of
beef soup you guys come with a beef soup
because I get this is what I've been
looking for you or is it cold right
Beast
I need some a deep soup for my dinosaur
it's a pet I have I should take it a
picture homeless be soup all right
buh-bye